une production du studio sfr bienvenue
au sans fil dans le podcast
on parle de ce qu'on veut nous
interactive super h 40 ans avec moi
d'une plante si vous voulez nous
entendre parler plus longuement de la
conversation vous allez entendre à
l'instant vous pouvez vous diriger vers
notre page piquionne ou on fait encore
moins de filtres ou est-ce que nicole
dos mais moins on jase la conversation
qu'on est d'avoir on va plus en
profondeur dans certains thèmes fait que
si vous voulez avoir accès à ce check et
seuls les liens vont être dans la
description cette semaine au podcast on
reçoit alexandre champagne et emmanuel
parents les deux mastermind derrière la
fondation le ciel
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
effet cela va la faculté de la des
sciences de l'administration pardon de
l'université laval
si on en parle depuis longtemps des
faisceaux de laval et si vous vous
demandez est-ce que je devrais
m'inscrire si vous voulez vous tremper
les pieds sans risque en fait est fait
sur laval offre le programme moque donc
le massive open online russe sur le
management durable donc c'est quoi le
mox est un programme qui est 100%
gratuit qui vous permet d'apprendre plus
de technique sur le management durable
dont vous vous expliquer ces quads en un
instant le prix un bouc s'est vraiment
pas un programme qui contraignant parce
que pas de date d'abandon parce que
c'est gratuit
vous vous inscrire suivent le cours et
quitter si à un moment donné ça fait pas
votre affaire ou si vous vous retrouvez
en une situation ce que vous avez pu le
temps avec dom tu me parles tu un petit
peu plus du management durable
web magazine durable management
responsable aussi qu'on appelle c'est
pas juste pour les personnes sont en
position de gestion sais pas si c'est
aussi pour les employés ou futurs
entrepreneurs qui veulent être des
acteurs de changement qui soit un acteur
de changement tu veux que ça change rue
une société plus durable plus
responsable par yarmouk
des formations vraiment très inspirante
chaque module repenser nos manières de
faire féconder construit ce qu'est la
société nous impose on repense
romantique night box
chaque semaine il ya des capsules vidéo
qui représente les sept valeurs propres
au management de responsables et cette
valeur je vous les nommez c'est
l'efficacité
l'intégrité le dévouement l'audace la
sude solidarité l'humilité et l'agilité
ça c'est l'agilité le cynisme valeurs
responsables surtout à donjons dragons
14 belle agilité c'est toujours bon de
répondre à l'or yorbeau des professeurs
sur cette plateforme l'oeil les
spécialistes qui viennent nous parler de
management responsable il ya plus de
vingt mille participants qui ont
complété déformation du mot cas alors
c'est vraiment ça a fait ses preuves
si vous voulez vous inscrire à la
quatrième édition du mot qu'on va mettre
le lien dans la gestion du podcast sur
ce merci fsu laval pour ce long
partenariat avec le sans filtre padilla
stpi bon succès à tout le monde qu'ils
souhaitent s'inscrire au mac book le
podcast de cette semaine et présenté par
mme anne skate
vous le savez on en parle pratiquement
tout le temps men skate c'est une
nouvelle obsession pour moi je vous ai
déjà parlé du fait que j'avais commencé
à utiliser leur parfum maintenant quand
j'ai pu le parfum skype jeu même pour
tous un peu toi moi je me sens pas
moindres les chiens je mets mon foulard
parce que mon flanc je me suis parfois
sur le flanc le sens puisque où ça sent
tellement bon que je tenais mon floch
comme content de le même temps ça me
rappelle le parfait mendy kate in depuis
que début je me suis teint parle je me
sens comme mon vrai moi c'est comme si
toute ma vie j'avais jamais été vraiment
moi que le fait d'avoir un parti comme
enfin y'a pas de 10 connecte en images
que je projette que je me sens
réellement tout séparé que le parfum
musqué des tons chauds servent députés
cette odeur le
h dans l'odeur concordent parfaitement
ça se peut ça ce puits en plus mes
tripes sais qui tu lis et d'odeurs là
pour mettre dans toutes les autres
produits comme par exemple céder de rang
pour bronze et le tourneur pour voir ce
que donne un petit vif rafraîchissement
de plus exacte d'un barman ont eux
rapidement d'un autre des produits même
si on parle de leurs produits en ont
plein que c'est la banque qui a plein de
produits d'enfants le 15 e ht le super
3.0 vous avez tout là dedans même des
boxeurs sont vraiment qu'on fout le
boxon en fait pourquoi graphique entre
vienne et orange
une douceur pour les bijoux de famille
la douceur ok sinon il ya les
croque-morts ce canton de saint-leu un
petit peu c'est divin jette dans le fond
c'est des lingettes humides etc sans
doute pas avec la même odeur de minsk
est comparé le leader l'audi du oud et
est descendu du ciel
sacré vous pouvez nettoyer comme ça
maintenant un peu le temps par une
douche venant du sport quoi que ce soit
un petit groupe map quand ils pourront
prendre l'avion de forme étant votre sac
vous êtes willy tugud c'est même un
journal avec plein d'informations le ja
oui c'est beau c'est écrit là dessus
allez voir sur leur site web pour toutes
les autres produits en un code promo
pour vous pour 20% de rabais avec le
shipping gratuit puis le code procès
sans fil de 20 pour 20% le rabais
merci merci beaucoup fait qu'une grosse
discussion cette semaine avec à la
grande champagne et emmanuel par an ça
fait longtemps que nous on parle des
réseaux sociaux on commence à en parler
de plus en plus on commence à ressentir
une espèce de bouillonnement qui nous
qui nous perturbent qui nous dérange qui
nous rend un petit peu anxieux pire ça a
été intéressant d'en parler avec deux
personnes qui sont spécialistes ont fait
que d'autres sont vraiment attardé et
comment gérer les réseaux sociaux de nos
jours
cette nouvelle entité qui est appelée
dans nos vies sans trop qu'on s'en rende
compte que maintenant on prend une place
immense qu'il faut apprendre à
apprivoiser tout simplement on pourra
retirer les bénéfices mais sans vivre
tout l'espère plus négatif et pernicieux
qui peut se retrouver à travers ces
réseaux sociaux moi j'aime le concept de
la conscience de prendre conscience
de ce que les réseaux sociaux nous
procure où nous nous font comme tard en
fait d'être capable de mettre un doigt
sur ce la première étape en fait de tout
absolution 6-1 contre d'un se rendent
compte qu'un problème en fait donc d'un
capable d'être encore d'analyser quelle
et arrêtent à relation à toi avec les
réseaux sociaux et ensuite pouvoir
mettre en place des mécanismes qui vont
permettre d'ajuster au mieux que
d'utiliser tous les bons côtés des
réseaux sociaux d'essayer de diminuer
les moins bons côtés fait que sans plus
attendre
on vous souhaite une bonne bombe à
castres bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes bienvenue à l'eau début de 3 go
c'est là c'est trop fort comme en va de
la santé exact n'a pas de sens m aussi
atteint h
oui c'est parfait mais
[Musique]
c'est du bon contenu des buts merci
d'être là merci des limitations
ça fait plaisir ce temps longtemps comme
un conte a écrit sur un petit boucan
manger c'est ouais je sais puis j'ai
besoin de faire une tête un peu et on
voulait banc jeudi aux invités manu
chanter chanter
manuel qui est que vous vous êtes
associé en fait dans la fondation
exactement ciel exactement
l'afld la fondation qui héberge dit
j'aime y survivent toujours un peu mal
avec ça parce que moi c'était une idée
était dans ma tête puis j'avais envie de
le développer avec des gens puis
l'histoire est fantastique je veux jeter
manu un as présente ensuite mais je veux
juste centre d'intelligence émotionnelle
exactement je veux je veux compter
comment j'ai rencontré manu parce que
c'est assez c'est assez extraordinaire
la vie est bonne quand il fait les
choses qui étaient envie de faire depuis
longtemps je pense puis ça dépend de
ckoi longtemps pour chacune des
personnes mais bref j'ai dit le 2
décembre 2010 non j'ai fait une vidéo
est ce que j'ai expliqué que je quittais
la photo sans tenter plus farceurs
j'avais plus envie d dans l'oeuf le
domaine que j'étais puis je mettais sur
pied une fondation qui s'appelle le ciel
le centre pour l'intelligence
émotionnelle en ligne puis le bus était
d'avoir une conversation sur les enjeux
de santé mentale qui sont liées aux
réseaux sociaux et le est une longue
vidéo peut-être de 10 minutes environ à
ce que j'explique que j'ai besoin de
quelqu'un pour m'aider à stratégie et
tous ceux comme un bras droit parce que
moi je m'étais dit baye a personne qui
va vouloir me suivre là dedans avec
cependant un beau jouer tout seul qu'il
va falloir que j'aille quelqu'un pour
m'aider avec l'organisation parce que
j'ai aucune aucun sens d'organisation
dans vie et là j'ai reçu dans l'heure
qui a suivi une centaine de courriels
avec des cv des choses comme ça que je
me suis dit allez que j'ai pas
d'organisation comment je dois faire
pour passer par dessus et j'ai donc
schooly à travers les emails de façon
aléatoire je tombe sur un nom je t'ai
emmanuel parra puis j'ai trouvé ça cool
parce que manu est rejeté un beau prénom
je gère ma fille à fille s'appelait
leiria sa gauche fait que jeanne en
effet il appelé manuel fait assez drôle
qui parent ça me faisait penser à mon
amie marie joëlle parents je sais pas si
vous l'avez déjà reçu ici majeur la
dette à san francisco une québécoise à
la fait tous les livres 300 raison de
mes plus grands une fille que j'aime
beaucoup
puis j'ai fait comme à emmanuel pas
rentrer je vole jusqu'à ce qu'un mot
écrit il avait défait point par point
toutes la vidéo que j'avais fait pour
m'expliquer comment la voyez ce piano
dit je suis doctorante en communication
université de montréal je t'aime sur les
normes sociales emprunté par les ados
sur les réseaux sociaux avec un mois et
de ce match ça tombe bien fait que j'ai
dis que tu venais de prendre un café
dimanche prochain on est le lundi ou le
mardi je pense à ce moment là un
dimanche en fête le dimanche après on
prend un café puis ça fait vingt minutes
qu'on jase plus j'écoute manu pour est
jamais s'attendre travailler que moi go
ça fait un an et demi qu'on se parle a
toujours très cool et il voit aussi
emmanuel par ammann a mis à l'eau j'ai
vu la vidéo d'art exemple chez tellement
j'étais en équipe et que quelqu'un se
pencher à faire du travail parle pas aux
médias sociaux
puis la santé mentale et c'est
d'ailleurs parce que moi je t'aime en 2e
année de dr heures puis bon pour ceux
qui font des études supérieures
les premières années c'est utilise
beaucoup d'articles tu lis des articles
scientifiques temps discute avec
d'autres chercheurs etc puis des fois
y'a c'était un manque de contact la tête
en train de fouler investir dans ton
intelligence tully plein de choses mais
pas seulement quelqu'un qui t'écoutent
pour le communiqué et l'accent mis par
philips midi
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que je dirai alexandre
l'absorber spa vide il remettait d'un
film ou fait comme une tempête
wes emprunter sur quoi est ce que dans
d'autres portait précisément
ouais mais la raison pour laquelle je me
suis inscrite au doctorat c'est parce
que ma maîtrise qui est aussi un projet
de recherche ça concernait les médias
sociaux
puis au fur et à mesure je lisais des
articles dont j'allais prendre à ma rue
mes amis je leur en parler puis au fil
et divers finalement comprenez il ya des
amis qui m'ont dit humanité quand il m'a
parlé qu'il y avait eu des études par
exemple sur les like sur les normes en
ligne bon qui sont inhérentes
concentrent notamment contre ça va
vraiment aider du pib puis j'ai mieux
ajuster mon utilisation et je réfléchis
plus avant de poster que cette erreur
fait que comac et je veux pousser là
dedans et puis au lieu d'aller avec les
jeunes adultes qui finalement tout les
jeunes adultes dans la mitaine etc on
est capable de faire une recherche
google
je ne sais pas évident savoir comment
mines utiliser les médias sociaux mais
on est quand même autonome tandis que
les ados je voyais qu'il y avait quand
même un accord à ce niveau là parce
qu'on disait beaucoup comment est-ce que
les ados de y avait beaucoup de
jugements en fils
comment est-ce qu utilisent les médias
sociaux et des d'inquiétude malveillance
des fois on va donc je disais me pencher
là dessus pour ces raisons là pour
partager savoirs avec eux que les
écouter qu'est ce qu'ils ont vraiment en
dire ou de l'autre qu'est ce qu'on
entend dans les médias dans mon sujet de
thèse en fait c'est des documents telle
expérience des ados en faisant des
entrevues des cours de discussion j'ai
eu ma première entrevue canada snap est
en plus aujourd'hui avec en faisant des
entrevues avec des ados et des groupes
de discussion puis de faire des liens
finalement entre leur expérience puis la
manière dont les plateformes sont
construites donc l'interface le ticket
ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas faire c'est
quoi les le lien entre leurs expériences
leurs sentiments leurs anticipations qui
est ce que les boutons des médias
sociaux nous suggère de faire rapidement
le c'est pas ma soeur mon rouge et
accentué mettons alex doivent là un an
et demi quand cette idée là c'est quoi
c'est quoi qui te fait dire c'est si
nécessaire cette formation lorsqu'elle
mettant aujourd'hui
regarde on y reviendra tantôt mais on
regarde les réseaux sociaux on regarde
les climats des réseaux sociaux on
regarde comment c'est dans les mains de
tout le monde commence à créer de
l'anxiété puis mettons aujourd'hui moi
je réalise qu'ils ont un problème tu es
dans les derniers mois mais ton je
réalise que l'oeil un problème tu as
évolué en un an et demi maintenant tu
dis ok je veux plus faire cette business
là qui est quand même succès qui était
la photographie fait que je veux laisser
derrière moi une autre entreprise avec
du succès mettons là pour une autre fois
dans ma vie puis je me lance là dedans
c'est quoi toutes questions remarques
dans le climat qu'est ce que tu
remarques qui fait si tu te crois
personnellement que tu as vécu si tu
dirais que c'est multifactoriel de sable
ça mais pas ça m'a pas si nappé d'une
chope waouh
eurêka j'ai trouvé m gg quand je suis
sorti de l'école nationale de l'humour
en 2007 j'ai commencé à faire de la
tournée de spectacles avec karine côté
on a fait beaucoup de shows dans des
écoles secondaires pour éduc'alcool on
allait parler de la modération sous le
couvert de l'humour pour encourager les
jeunes à se questionner sur leur
consommation d'alcool puis moi le
feeling le sentiment que j'ai eu quand
j'arrivais dans les écoles secondaires
c'est que les ados étaient des éponges
mettre les ados avaient aussi une
manière de voir les choses dont on
n'entendait pas parler publiquement
nécessairement fait je crois qu'il me
manquait une voie publique pour ce
groupe los de personnes qui sont entre
l'enfance et l'âge adulte mais qui ont
encore assez de candeur pour se
prononcer sur des enjeux sociaux avec la
bienveillance mais qui ont encore pas
assez d'expérience de maturité pour
poser des actions concrètes pour que ça
change
et puis avec la photographie puis les
réseaux sociaux j'ai pas ce que tu dis
tu te rends tu t'es rendu compte et un
ami qui avait un problème ça fait
plusieurs années que j'entends des
enjeux sur les médias sociaux qui s'en
viennent puis une autre affaire aussi
c'est que à un moment donné j'ai fait
comme j'ai vraiment été chanceux d'avoir
eu autant de succès grâce aux médias
sociaux que je te parle de succès pas en
terme d'être connus ou de visibilité aux
rêveurs mais les projets qu'on a fait je
pars je parle de contrôle de go
en 2008 on a été les premiers jonathan -
l'équipe à gagner des oliviers dans la
catégorie contenus numériques au début
les gens trouvaient ça un peu étrange
pitié dans le temps on disait ça c'est
juste du web si c'est un budget pour le
web on a eu comme il place pour faire
contrôler golfe allaient payer tout le
monde et on a vu contre le seconder eu
du succès avec ça ensuite deux ou trois
fois par jour quand je dis à mes proches
et je vois faire un bloc de bourbon à
londres est ce vraiment hilarante
comprends mais après ce bon trois fois
par jour a été le succès que s'arrêter
puis encore une fois je peux pas me
l'approprier tout seul à un certain
moment donné autour de 2016-2017 antenne
vingtaine à temps plein j'ai fait comme
moi les médias sociaux sans les médias
sociaux ça aurait été extrêmement du sud
avant ce succès le jeu qu'on parle
disons au succès de ricardo josée di
stasio même daniel pinard à l'époque
c'est des gens qui avaient travaillé
vraiment vraiment fort qui avait écrit
plusieurs livres qui ont d d d d d d
plusieurs années télévision pour en
arriver au même succès aux autres grâce
aux médias sociaux
on a pris comme un raccourci pour né
dans le vélo on est arrivé puis il y en
a pas un qui est meilleur que l'autre ou
à la russie jusqu'à les outils de
l'époque nous auront permis d'y arriver
plus rapidement un pire moment donné on
été approché par une grosse compagnie
d'épicerie puis nous ont dit on va vous
engager parce qu'on veut que votre page
facebook soit aussi effervescente que
ils ont dit on veut que notre page
facebook and ou l'épicerie soit aussi
effervescente que la vôtre j'ai dit
c'est impossible on est des individus
vous êtes une entreprise y a personne
qui va vous parler les gens vont chez
vous parce que bon il ya la proximité et
puis les rabais nous on est des
personnes fait quand on dit quelque
chose des gens savent qu'ils peuvent
répond qu' on va répondre voire une
interaction il va y avoir une connexion
ils le sentiment de connexion qu'on a
sur les médias sociaux étaient là et un
moment donné j'ai dit à marie lou il va
avoir un problème a mené parce que les
individus vont se comporter comme des
marques que les marques vont se
comporter comme des individus
ça m'aide mélanger je pense qu'il va y
avoir des enjeux liés à ce je suis pas
encore capable de bien définir le fasse
avec avec un bon esprit de synthèse
comment ça c'est remplacer
c'est vraiment vraiment intéressant que
que tu voyais venir que les individus
vont se comporter comme des marques ou
les marques comme des individus
je lui dis en 2014 en afrique qu'est-ce
que tu voyais comme problème avec ça
mais mettons tout aimé ton si ça
arrivait dans le futur qu'est ce qui
allait être la problématique pour moi
c'est les débuts de la reconnaissance
que les médias sociaux tout en tout cas
la majorité des connexions con
sur les médias sociaux entre les
personnes sont basés ou sont encouragés
par des modèles économiques que ce soit
des connexions amical par exemple va
devenir ami avec toi ph parce que je
sais que tu as un podcast puis
éventuellement moi je mets par une
business j'aimerais ce qui m'avait tu as
ton podcast que je suis peut-être la
visibilité jeu devient ami avec toi on a
une connexion mais en même temps on est
comme des amis avec des bénéfices le je
te parle moneta sortie dans l'extrême le
donc je deviens ni avec toi la connexion
qu on ne l est basée sur un modèle
économique de perte ou de gains non sens
où quand je suis dans ton cercle g1 gh1
à faire éventuellement alors je vais
m'approcher toit puis je veux créer la
relation comme ceux plus les plateformes
se développe plus on encourage ce type
de connexion le parce qu'il ya un groupe
qui s'appelle tristana risque partie le
center for human technology qui a aussi
un podcast qui s'appelle lieu en dvd de
trencin pilleurs podcast au complet sur
la dépendance puis le chercheur
britannique qui vient dont le nom
m'échappe
il vient parler du fait que le contrat
dépendance c'est pas l'abstinence c'est
la connexion à partir du moment où on
établit une connexion avec quelque chose
qui est basé sur son système de valeurs
une chose qui va te faire une chose qui
va qui va créer dans ton cerveau la même
réaction que quand tu prends de la
drogue ou de l'alcool ou quelque chose
qui va t'aider à être heureux le jeune
vulgarise grossièrement là mais c'est
vraiment une connexion donc ce que nous
offrent les médias sociaux en surface il
le fait de pouvoir connecter jeu peut
connecter avec d'autres vous autres sur
les médias sociaux
après ça aussi que les algues vont
favoriser des connexions entre des gens
qui ont peut-être par rapport à nous qui
ont des intérêts similaires
et donc on force le genre de connexion
qui est basée sur un modèle économique
parce que le but des plateformes c'est
de nous de garder le plus longtemps
possible pour nous faire acheter des
patentes
m mais cette collection nation si on se
penche vers les jeunes est ce que cette
collection lab basé sur un modèle
économique se traduit aussi vers des
connexions pour amo aguets montée en
fait dans les rangs de ce géant maison
les rangs de popularité dans la vraie
vie
ouais c'est une bonne question mais
c'est un peu
finalement le reflet des
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cour d'école
a dîné avec 3,4 de tes amis tout le
temps ben c'est avec culture interagir
sur les médias sociaux donc si la mixité
mais rami a publié une photo d'un comme
ton statut social dépend du sien
intitulé l'externat lisbonne serment
comme ça mais c'est un peu un instinctif
comme on la même chose que si je me
promène avec mon ami à l'école par une
grosse cachent des ketchups jean
dégueulasse sur son chandail je sais pas
pourquoi leur est seul à manger des hot
deux périodes mais dépassé marche à côté
de cet ami leur fac tu es un associé à
sa tâche de ketchup a elle aussi factiva
y penser ta veste pour la couvrir
mais c'est un peu la même chose si ton
ami a fait un post sur les médias
sociaux
ben on va souvent voir cette et des amis
proches tu vas aller commenté où on est
c'est tellement magnifique était d'aller
en raquettes ce week end là où c'était
comment ta mère vous avez fait une
sortie bla bla bla doit interagir avec
son contenu parce que tu veux pas
qu'elle perde la face tu veux pas de ton
ami soit triste la rétroaction de ses
pairs sur sa publication donc mais en
encourageant ta copine est où ton ami
peinture hao son statut sa carrière m es
le tient également métier sociale c'est
comme si on a besoin de connecter on
s'associe aux autres adolescents sont
définis beaucoup par nos amis et c'est
un autre exemple pour illustrer ça ça
serait quand c'est la fête
une de tes amis ou d'un thé ami malade
tu veux pas d'histoires et instagram
disons ou est-ce que tu iras en marche
après une folle mais les deux sont
faciles ça c'est faut faire attention
avec ceux de 10 mettant dualité et les
deux sens positif c'est juste que en fx
et si une de mes amies me tombait
d'estoril moi à ma retraite
ça me déçoit rhinois ma part je trouvais
ça comme qui ocz com merci mais c'est
moins riche que si elle m'appelle mais
ça m'a pas dit que ces images des fois
on attendait didier je te le dis avec un
ton un peu condescendant puis
c'est un réflexe qu'on a aussi puis
c'est une bonne chose d'eux à faire
quand tu as dit est ce que ça change des
liens entre les ados les jeunes ce qu'on
a réalisé avec les balises études qu'on
appuie nous les questions qu'on a posé
aux ados quand les interviews wever sait
que les ados communique énormément en dm
à travers les plateformes de médias
sociaux
ça c'est une des manières qu'ils ont
trouvée puissance a été exacerbée à
cause de la pandémie semaine qu'ils ont
trouvé de garder une connexion puis je
veux juste dire un truc je disais tantôt
quand on faisait contre 2 go on avait un
budget pour le web les gens crachaient
sur le web littéralement jusqu'à temps
qu'ils aient des gouvernements
commencent à offrir des bourses de comme
cent mille places à des émissions de
télé pour qu'il puisse avoir des sites
internet pour supporter le lait chaud
des livres je voulais je te dis encore
une fois grossièrement l'on s'est rendu
compte qu'il ya du sirius money dans
l'internet et là un des enjeux auxquels
on fait face c'est que on considère
encore le web comme un non lieu
puis tous les interactions sur le web
comme des interactions qui sont pas
importantes
alors qu' elles ont des réelles
conséquences sur notre psyché et nos
émotions dans la vraie vie fait pour moi
c'est vraiment important de ne pas
renvoyer du revers l'âme de la main les
choses qui se passe sur internet par
exemple idiot je lisais avec un ton
condescendant
moi aussi ça m'arrive souvent de franco
semioli zamil qui commandent piéger
comme appris à ne pas avoir cette
réaction est une réaction qui est normal
quand quelque chose qui est loin de nous
au quelque chose qui quand quelqu'un
fait quelque chose que nous on ferait
pas je sais pas c'est quoi ce réflexe là
d'où ça vient on attend sans fin comme
mais oui c'est comme quand je me suis
fait tatouer plat denise bombardier
faisait des trucs sur l'état touche
comme si denise je l'ait pas fait
tatouer sur toi mon grand pape est un
fake comme qu'est ce tu veux beaucoup de
réactions la témoin quand même d'un
malaise dont on est conscient mais qu'on
a de la misère à mettre des mots dessus
mais c'est le fait de poser tout le
temps de virtuel pirée
le rapport d'un sapeur quand même qu'on
est capable de dire qu'une différence en
parler à des amis par message par
facebook il vous rend face à face et
c'est ce qui nous fait les opposer les
deux camps de dire qu'alain qui mieux
que l'autre etc
mais en fait c'est vraiment comme en
communication on va parler une théorie
de la richesse du médium qui donc par
exemple le podcast comme quelqu'un qui
coûterait pas de casse en ce moment
seulement audio mais il ya accès à
autant de voix annonce d'impression nos
expressions à cancon scoop et c'est ça
qui est une richesse qui comme maton qui
passe surtout par le le ton de la voix
par le dio que la maison qui va
l'écouter par et vidéo mais ça va être
plus riche que médias parce que pour la
même j'ai qu'ils vont nous voir
physiquement ils vont devoir bouger non
verbale et c'est donc on comprend un peu
qu'elle me trompe textos qui plus buggy
moins riches cheikhs en tête en face à
face puis ou du partage vraiment
beaucoup et de non verbale
au delà des paroles qui étudie donc
c'est pour ça qu'elle est virtuel c'est
moins satisfaisant c'est comme si tu es
c'était triste qui ont vitalement en ce
moment qu'on dépend des médias sociaux
pour parler à nos amis puis on a besoin
pour rejoindre notre famille mais en
même temps il tout le temps comme 707
sensation lors que c'est pas assez
unique il rien qui remplace comme quand
quelqu'un est pris ce le fait de la
série dans tes bras est petit
y'a pas de mots mais c'est comme tu dis
à la personne qui était l'un des
facteurs nous parle des camps alexandrie
la super étude qui comme la connexion
connexions nouvelle addiction c'est vrai
que la connexion est il plus important
est la solution aux problèmes de
dépendance c'est que c'était sans que
dams a décroché son téléphone de peur
d'avoir une dépendance c'était parce que
tous ces besoins de connexion l'est
vraiment profondément au aux pontois
puis tu essayes de pallier ce besoin de
validation social petites connexions
sociales et ton téléphone mais ça te
laisse tout le temps surtout allemagne
tandis qu est ce pour se réorienter vers
du face à face b c'est en cela que le
virtuel est mal mais ça va être beaucoup
plus nourrissants on s'en est rendu
compte assez rapidement tda au début de
la pandémie quand on s'est mis à faire
des zooms sans arrêt
avec ta femme et avec ses amis puis
enfin laquelle vous pouvoir est pas
grave on va faire des zooms pourront
faire des jeux on va faire décider ce
mois s'est rapidement rendu compte que
justement ça pouvait jamais remplacer
une vraie interaction humaine
puis quand on a sorti souvent plus
drainer plus fatigué qu'avant si c'est
vrai c'est pourquoi j'aime ça c'est
l'aspect scientifique l'a choisi lui la
tipp j'ai donné du 9 avril au 9 mai 2020
j'ai donné trente quatre sessions de
deux heures sur zoom à des gens qui
voulaient avoir des cours de photo puis
ça m'a pris à peu près trois mois j'ai
fait comme un burn-out plus belle je me
suis mis à faire de l'art et non parce
que plus on en parle parce que même si
j'avais mon cerveau était littéralement
fondu ce week-end la thermodynamique la
loi qui dit que quand tu envoies de
l'énergie sans nécessairement un retour
quand tu parles devant un écran à des
gens qui l'ont enlevé un écran de y'a
pas de retour c'est comme si tu payes tu
es dans le vide
un taux qui n'existe pas fait dépense de
l'énergie mais t'as pas de retour puis
je me fie à mes années de spectacle
quand je faisais des shows puis j'avais
je sentais la couarde
je savais comment les gens se sentaient
je savais quel rythme
à quel rythme envoyez les blagues je
savais quand arrêter quand poursuivre
quand renchérir la mongole sur the moon
a mis ses pas que le timing est ainsi
que la connexion six spots manqué le
même degré de rapidité de connexion
c'est pas tout le monde qui que la même
là même le même degré d'attention
puis il n'y a pas d'énergie qui est reçu
cinq ans quand on regarde la télé était
passif que jamais actif quand tu
regardes un écran de la majorité du
temps alors que l'on nous demande est
actif devant un écran puis çà çà çà des
faits certaines règles la loi de la
thermodynamique dans le sens où tu
envoies d'énergie que tu recevras plus
jamais être fcc essayé moi je me
souviens avant la pub avant la fin mai
comme par le milieu je n'étais jamais de
boyer je pouvais boyer le 10 fois de
suite sans arrêt j'étais comme on dit
mais qu'est ce qui change tellement
fatigué mais c'est juste que j'en vois
je respire pas je parle je parle pas
puis je parle fort mais je parle vite
parce que je veux que les gens restent
le sois concentré parce que j'ai pas de
retour au fait que c'est vraiment
vraiment rageant quand même
comme comme manière de communiquer nous
elle fait démontré aussi qui est on
exagère nous et après j'avais des
marionnettes - bonjour plus d'énergie
qu'ils avaient lutté jusqu'à nier tout
le temps micro délais quand tu parles
sur un zoom soit fait sans que ce puits
jusqu'à ton cerveau tu es comme pieds au
dessus de cloche est quelque chose qui
le critiquent que tu reçois pas en temps
réel cache-t-elle dit il ça gruge
d'énergie suscite fac bref avec les
réseaux sociaux ce qu'on cherche
finalement ça serait de remplacer
interactions humaines qui le remplacera
mais finalement c'est complémentaire
beaucoup de ces factures en place des
liens sociaux mais qu'il est
complètement sûr que ce soit mais
quelqu'un qui voudrait qu'il voudrait en
fait remplacé ce rejet mais c'est
finalement non parce que parce que
l'interaction s'est jamais satisfaisante
n'est pas ce qui l'attend face à face
comme on vit en ce moment même si on a
un plexi on nous deux c'est quand même
un indicateur de bien-être qui est
vraiment plus respirer même moi j'ai dit
je fais ma thèse en comme le jeu en
question que je peux capable de décrire
la complexité de ce qui est bon dans une
interaction face à face la travers tout
le non verbal c'est tellement pris 6 pi
s'est dit c'est le maître ligne là
dessus mais c'est là un écouteur depuis
tantôt par exemple il ya juste un petit
quelque chose que je me questionne sait
on semble prendre pour acquis que
l'interaction est nécessairement fait
que ces cas qu'on dit c'est en tout cas
qu'on disait si une connexion ou si je
commence pourrait aussi monter le social
finalement si jamais genuine soleil
brille principalement rien de mal à sa
pizza en fait c'est que l'environnement
numérique des des réseaux sociaux
favorisent ce type de connexion de nous
ça veut pas dire que c'est ce qui va
arriver
je veux toujours faire un exemple
inverse les autoroutes les rues des
pancartes il ya de la signalisation ça
favorise la sécurité s'est reposé qui
aura pas d'accident si c'est un peu la
même affaire je veux juste revenir un
peu en arrière pour complémenter le
point de bonus qui circule chez les
jeunes si on veut ma phrase n'a aucun
sens mais si on va voir chez des
adolescents au niveau du développement
cognitif et comportemental les
interactions sociales sont une bonne
manière de développer l'intelligence
émotionnelle l'intelligence émotionnelle
c'est le camping parqués derrière tes
émotions
puis qui peut aider à développer ton
empathie et d'état bienveillance entre
autres choses si on enlève aux ados la
possibilité de se voir et de communiquer
des personnes placées
c'est comme l'enjeu principal qu'on a
ciblé qu'est ce que les médias sociaux
peuvent enlever aux jeunes c'est
beaucoup de temps de personne à personne
c'est comme la faire là je dirais en ce
moment kiki qui pose le plus gros
problème si on veut aux ados on sait que
le quai dans le film de sochaux de la
main il parle du taux de suicide qui
augmente mais pas de corrélation dans
une enseigne la corrélation n'y a pas de
causalité
c'est pas à cause de ça ça peut être à
cause de son nom ne peut prouver c'est à
cause de tout ce qu'on sait c'est que
les ados se voit de moins en moins de
personne à personne par des mines ou pas
il y avait une tendance vers c'est parce
que il remplacer leurs interactions par
l'étude si c'est plus facile
c'est difficile à dire aussi été c'est
multifactoriel ça peut être aussi les
parents qui sont plus payés en glandant
à leurs enfants mais appelle ton ami au
lieu d'aller marcher parce que moi ça
m'inquiète quand sort le soir le ski
légitime ou 6 2 6 on sait pas
précisément qu'est ce qui peut causer
cela mais oui mais toi la france mais
non jumeaux la rue on est plus en dedans
sociaux sur les jeux des autres ont fait
il ya plus aussi que le temps d'écran de
loisirs des jeunes augmenté de manière
significative
puis on sait aussi grâce à la direction
régionale de la santé publique de
montréal que un temps de loisirs temps
d'écran de loisirs augmentée est égale à
une augmentation de mauvais symptôme
comme par exemple l'anxiété l'angoissé
la dépression le sommeil aussi la
qualité du sommeil qui est très
importante pour avoir de l'énergie puis
comme être en vie et jettent un peu
dessus mais c'est juste pour dire que
oui les réseaux sociaux vont favoriser
s'appuie
là où la fondation veut agir c'est au
niveau des individus nous d'une manière
de faire les choses c'est empathie
bienveillance et un parlement j'ai pas
trouvé d'équivalent français pour
internet
la définition dirais que c'est habile le
fait d'habiter quelqu'un doit faire
quelque chose chacun parle mais quelque
chose de plus puissant en empathie
bienveillance nous ce qu'on veut c'est
d'entendre le feeling général par
rapport aux médias sociaux puis
d'essayer d'agir là dessus mais au
niveau de l'individu
nous on va parler d'un mal inconnu chez
facebook faisait arrêter de nous
proposer des annonces
parce qu'il ya encore un petit groupe de
gens qui ont énormément de pouvoir qui
ont beaucoup de contrôle sur nos
gouvernements et sur notre manière
d'agir avec les réseaux sociaux étant
donné que les réseaux sociaux sont
gratuits on devient le produit en étant
le produit si on change notre manière
d'être
ils vont devoir changer leur manière de
nous vendre je dois donner un exemple
vraiment niaiseux avec trois fois par
jour on vendait des chemins de table
c'est quoi des chemins talent sana faty
mais dans le milieu de la table du magny
chandelle puis des affaires dessus pour
que ça fasse beau on a réalisé que les
gens s'en servait comme napperons ça
qu'on a changé de nom pour napperons
puis on nous a vendu comme dix fois plus
fait qu'on ne pas changer le produit on
a changé la manière de le vendre et ça
tout ça fait la différence dans la
manière de vente sont donc je pense que
si on n'aime pas ou les individus à
comprendre pourquoi leur vulnérabilité
psychologique sont sont affectés ou sont
utilisés pour qu'on les garde le plus
longtemps
on va changer la manière d'interagir
avec les réseaux sociaux mais un autre
affaire aussi les réseaux sociaux n'ont
pas créé de nouveaux problèmes
ils ont exacerbé des problèmes qu'on
avait des jeux la comparaison le fait de
pas être bien dans son corps à cause des
images projetées josé les magazines la
télévision ça fait des années que ça
arrive c'est juste encore peu avec les
médias sociaux parce que notre cerveau a
une capacité de générer du contenu qui
est immensément plus grande que sa
propre capacité à en consommer bien
comprendre qu'il y en a simulé fait que
c'est un autre enjeu qu'on a aussi
auquel on s'adresse avec la france
surtout c'est c'est tellement d'affaires
différence est pas une chose juste à
cause des like an et demi mme seillé
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choses
mais on est comme en écho on est
clairement en fait c'est la
problématique c'est quoi exactement
fatalement une augmentation de bram de
santé mentale à court de réseaux sociaux
c'est ça notre combat
faut juste savoir répond ah qu'ils
avaient besoin flamand ou acquis
problématique s'est dit fier de répondre
maintenant parce que ce qui arrive avec
les médias sociaux c'est que ça a
commencé autour de 2005 facebook 2006 et
à chaque année l'outil change moi car
j'ai des gens qui m'approche pour me
demander comment tu as fait pour avoir
du succès sur facebook avec trois par
jour j'en ai aucune idée
en 2013 2012 2013 quand on a lancé
d'euros par jour par exemple contre gand
2008 mais la plateforme était
complètement différente le y avait
beaucoup moins de monde
les algorithmes était pas aussi
perfectionné l'intelligence artificielle
avait pas cette capacité de générer du
contenu de générer des algorithmes au au
fur et à mesure que les gens
consommaient du contenu fake je ne sais
pas fait qu'est-ce qu'on essaie de
combattre on essaie de combattre le
manque d'éthique dans la manière de
programmer les algorithmes au niveau des
réseaux sociaux pourquoi parce qu'on a
un problème
par contre cela ce nouveau le nom ben
c'est de faire changer c'est faire
changer le comportement d'un individu
pour que les compagnies sont obligées de
changer leur horrible
si si si facebook c'est que moi je me
limite à deux heures de temps d'écran
ils vont faire comme il le faudrait
qu'ils reviennent plus l'appeler ils
vont essayer de faire venir plus souvent
mieux résister à ça parce que je le sais
que c'est un piège pour me faire rêver
le plus souvent le maire exemple que je
peux te donner c'est la polarisation la
polarisation ça fait en sorte que bon je
vous donne un exemple le new york times
fait souvent des publications sur
d'autres la moitié des commentaires sont
comme on a ide en outre un peu l'autre
moitié des commentaires sont comme fuck
you by dane d'aucune manière dans ces
discussions le il ya quelqu'un qui va
changer d'idée et puis dans le fond tout
est fait pour ça parce que si toi tu
détestes rome autant chance de voir un
article qu'il bâche qui n'est autre que
tu as de chances de voir un article qui
fait l'éloge de ce colosse new yorkais
continuent de faire des articles au
dessus parce que ça crée l'engagement
voile qui tu sais quand tu te demande
qu'est-ce qu'on combat finalement mais
ma première réponse à ce rythme tu l'as
dit alexandre les médias sociaux ont
rien créé si vous voulez c'est le
problème qui existait déjà des
phénomènes qui sont déjà l'ex ont
exacerbé qui sont devenus plus
importants pour moi qu'est-ce qu'on
combat c'est l'agent de désinformation
les faits le manque d'éducation parce
que les médias sociaux on en a tous
on a tous des téléphones intelligents
dans nos poches en tout cas pour la
grande majorité et on les utilise tous
les jours on utilise plusieurs heures
par jour mais on comprend pas c'est quoi
un pas qu'ils ont sur nous mais depuis
on avait laissé entrer quelqu'un chez
nous pendant dix ans qui ont réalisé
qu'ils pètent désarroi d'un coin de la
maison fouillée bras puis on sait même
pas comment qui fait de l'argent si fac
jeudi en expliquant aux gens le média
social son but c'est de garder ton
intention mais l'autre peut déjà prendre
conscience des tpr auprès de tes propres
difficultés
c'est comme quand on fait des ateliers
dans les écoles secondaires
un expert des ateliers d'autodéfense
numérique puis on va présenter aux
jeunes par exemple comment est-ce que
les écrans et nuitée netflix avait dit
que son plus grands compétiteurs
s'étaient pas youtube sont plus grands
compétiteurs c'est le sommeil parce que
qu'est-ce que tu les entends dormir ou
le prochain épisode
c'est sa vraie compétition exactement ça
manque quand tu sais ce à partir du
moment où tu écoutes et comme un oiseau
à qui donc maintenant je comprends mieux
ce que j'utilise chaque jour évidemment
on qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est que je te
les personnes deviennent plus consciente
des outils qu'on utilise tellement bon
goût qui freinent paul de place dans
notre vie avec six mois j'ai une
sensibilité avec mon image corporelle et
alexandre n'y a plus une sensibilité
chez pas avec n'importe quoi d'autre
l'apex à dire que moi je vais laisser là
mais ça veut dire qu'ils aiment
moi si j'ai une sensibilité avec des
troubles alimentaires par exemple une
difficulté - est relié à ce site wap et
une bise nice-matin difficulté monte à
être lié à autre chose était donc c'est
pour ce qui est de mettre le doigt sur
les médias sociaux
mon problème chacun commence à nous
affecte c'est très différent parce que
ça reste un média à travers lesquels les
problèmes circule que l'autre chose
aussi je finis sur l'autre chose d'aussi
sixt instinct les réseaux sociaux sont
adaptés à notre manière de s'en servir
donc moi je serai pas comment dire à
facebook de changer de se changer
lui-même pour pourtant limitée ou pour
la tienne ou pour celle de manu je sais
comment et pour s adapter à la mienne
par exemple c'est ce qui est important
de comprendre tu parlais tantôt teaser
qui fait que dans le fond le but ultime
c'est de prévenir les enjeux de santé
mentale qui sont liés à l'utilisation
entre autres l'autre affaire c'est qu'on
veut que ces réseaux sociaux le arrête
d'âgés
en toute impunité sur ce qu'ils veulent
je donne un exemple pas je parlé d'
atteinte à la démocratie ok on sait
qu'ils les plateformes de médias sociaux
sont propices à la polarisation la
polarisation c'est peut-être le plus
grand ennemi de la démocratie ce qui est
dans un système démocratique idéalement
on se met au centre puis on se dit
qu'est ce qui serait le mieux on
s'écoute on prend le temps de consulter
puis quand on a trouvé la solution qui
fait plaisir à tout le monde on mais on
prend des actions concrètes pour changer
les choses
c'est difficile dans un climat de
polarisation parce que tu as des gens
qui sont campés dans leur position tant
d'autres personnes qui sont campés puis
le seul lien possible
c'est un débat c'est un débat stérile
qui mène nulle pas fake je prends
l'exemple de facebook aux philippines
je pense que ce trophée du pin c'est ce
que je me trompe mais ils sont arrivés
là-bas pillon dit à la plus grande
compagnie de télécommunication écoutez
nous on va offrir à vos utilisateurs
d'avoir internet gratuitement on paye le
dater use it je fais que dans le fond
pas la date à devaux de vos abonnés
seulement s'ils vont sur internet à
partir de facebook soit et aux
philippines t'as pas énormément dessous
pour te payer une connexion sur internet
mais tu veux rester connectés que ta
famille est ce que tu veux juste une
connexion faculty du bon mais je vais
pas nier ce téléphone là parce que
facebook est imbriqué dedans je te parle
dans le vide pour eux internet facebook
exactement le problème c'est que là tu
arrives sur facebook puis facebook
utilise t vulnérabilité psychologique
pour te garder le plus longtemps c'est
le même principe aux philippines que ce
qu'à montréal c'est la même chose puis
on est des humains donc on a tous les
mêmes systèmes à peu près d'émotion ou
de houe de régulation de celle-ci et et
compagnie hélas ce qui arrive c'est que
facebook arrive la bop lui donne accès à
internet à tout le monde c'est
clairement le club gay comme jeu permet
à tout le monde d'être sur internet
voire bravo marque c'est fantastique le
problème c'est que les mêmes problèmes
sociaux se passe là bas et donc les
partis politiques se servent de facebook
pour faire de la désinformation pour
arriver au pouvoir arrive au pouvoir
commencent à voter des lois plus
facebook comme au shit faut concentrer
parce que ça va chier les mecs et là ils
partent ils y ont le droit d'arriver de
phoque est un système puis de repartir
puis a personne qui peut leur taper sur
les doigts puis a personne qui peut agir
sur quoi que ce soit alors qu'on est
capable de lier la responsabilité à
facebook sauf c'est un très très grand
enjeu autant que pour une personne qui
peut passer des heures instagram puis
commencer à s'enliser dans des pensées
dépressive dans des pensées même
suicidaire des fois
c'est un autre problème aussi c'est deux
très graves problèmes il faut il faut
s'adresser à ces problèmes là comme un
bain en mettant à jour notre
connaissance sur les médias sociaux puis
aussi en leur demandant d'agir en toute
transparence je pense mais ce après ça
c'est so cesser ce serait dans le fond
mais comme ces deux enjeux du fargy est
différent prenons l'enjeu sur la société
comme common par les athlètes un petit
peu plus macro puis la solution là
dessus c'est de dire ça passe par
comment nous on consomme pipeau
éventuellement faire changer en eau
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque
chose qui m'échappe et ce must par
rapport à l' influence de chacun sur des
modèles comme sur le tir c'est comme
quand que je parle de véganisme souvent
dire et là on va tout le monde réduire
notre consommation je suis pas sûr ça va
changer grand chose tant que pas
quelqu'un qui va prendre une décision en
rôti fait que mettons sur des compagnies
privées comme facebook twitter comment
est ce qu'on vient réglementer ce en
tant que société démocratique
la fête du cheval sont le changement
veut plus tôt venait comme tu dis de
réglementation plutôt que de
conscientisation baisse parce que si
tout le monde on charge aux habitudes
sur tige 1 tandis que leur objectif à
eux c'est de nous prendre dans un
mécanisme qui doit dire oui ok grand
justement à des fondations comme la
vôtre de dirait on peut apprendre à se
détendre et ses mécanismes là mais j'ai
comme le feeling que la masse va quand
même resté coincé dans les mécanismes
pecten ce sera pas une décision que va
se prendre en main pour se saluer ça va
prendre des efforts concertés
oui mais si c'est ça après c'est
évidemment que des limites à dire tu es
c'est comme ça fait beaucoup penser sur
l'autre le parallèle avec les big and
his past avait beaucoup pensé à la cause
environnementale où on dit c'est les
gestes de chacun qui seront la somme du
changement c'est vrai qu'une grande part
de vérité là-dedans mais c'est ça quand
il ya des décisions vers le haut disons
que c'est un grand un duo c'est un grand
accélérateur
après ça dépend de ta posture politique
en fait si toi tu crois qu'ils devraient
avoir de la réglementation comme au
québec on est un peu plus d'intervention
de l'état que aux états unis par exemple
beaucoup
donc si
on se dit mais nous l'état ont fait
quinze jours 1 on veut qu'ils jouent un
rôle dans notre collectivité
on va se dire oui à qui le pouvoir aux
gens mais on veut aussi une certaine
législation mais qu'ils soient votés
avec notre gouvernement que c'était là
je pensais plus fédérale ce qui est
question des médias sociaux le met sa
touche la santé en tout cas bref si j'ai
aussi si le niveau de juridiction
mais ils ont un long et a pourrait
décider que c'est pas comme ceux qui
veulent fonctionner fait le disque
devant ça vient politique on convint
intervenir avec 7
et puis les gens qui sont élus sont élus
par une masse de gens puis si cette
masse de gens là est capable d'être au
spectre sion pour un rapport de
conscientisation
ben c'est là qu'on avance technique
quand je parle des prospections c'est
moins le véganisme ça m'a toujours
fasciné ça m'intéresse est ce que demain
matin je veux mais tu as eu je pense pas
j'ai besoin de vos plumes en même temps
une condition chronique je suis
diabétique le lexique quand même assez
compliqué de gérer ça mais je sais qu'il
y en a qui sont aux diabétiques et vegan
qui j'ai énormément d'admiration pour ça
mais on ne construit en douze mois moi
je suis pas c'est sûr qu'il ya eu un
moment donné du harcèlement fait auprès
de marie autre fois par jour par rapport
à l'avion mais comme vraiment être
désagréable mouche prête à vous entendre
avec avec grand plaisir n'importe qui en
face à sao discuter j'ai besoin
d'information puis comme puis le jeu
portrait de le faire du tout parler
sinon plus je prendrai le dire aux gens
comment s'exprimer mais c'est parce qu'à
un moment donné si tu veux réussir à
avoir gain de cause à un grand groupe de
gens il va falloir que tu te battre
contre les autres compagnies puis les
autres entités qui s'y prennent de la
meilleure manière possible pour faire
passer des messages
puis il faut savoir aussi que c'est pas
parce que c'est plus sophistiqué que
c'est moins violent
si je parle de m quel exemple j'aurais
donné mais je trouvais que la cause
vegan c'est bon c'est parce qu'on sait
que bon l'industrie de la viande ce
sacré des problèmes d'environnement des
choses comme ça mais c'est parce qu'à un
moment donné quand 45 personnes qui
commence a dit m en en rage et puis que
les ils font juste de traiter des
pépites t'as pas compris bits en vo
juste des visites images d'animaux et ma
petite fille qu un b c'est parce que là
j'ai juste plus envie de vous entendre
j'ai juste puis on veut vous entendre
même si la cause est importante la marre
de faire de metz est génial maintenant
il mate un impôt puisque tu veux
idéalement c'est d'atteindre le plus
grand nombre possible par le plus grand
nombre possible décide de changer sa
manière de faire mais là ça devient
difficile avec les médias sociaux parce
que la polarisation fait plus de se voir
mameri plus soit adressé aux gens qui
pensent paris comme toi fini tu veux
juste prêcher pour sa paroisse puis de
changera pas les choses
d'où l'importance d'une plus grande
connexion entre humains en personne et
d'où l'importance de la compréhension
des mécanismes derrière la manière
d'abord de la découvrabilité sur les
médias sociaux points pis sa propre ça
pose un enjeu aussi pour les personnes
minorisées et marginalisés et c'est là
qu'on a on commence à rentrer dans leur
culture
moi ce que je sais que tu voulais qu'on
adresse ans ont un projet tombé
là-dedans sud sud mais on peut y aller
aussi est juste un autre aspect que dit
tantôt que je veux rebondir juste avant
qu'on passe à autre chose
quant à 10 c'est comme si on avait
laissé entrer quelqu'un dans ma maison
qui dix ans plus tard on réalise la
personne et le puy que finalement sa
cause qui avait quelqu'un qui mange et
nono snack qu'on avait plus de snacks le
soir puis qu'on est un peu malheureux
tour de snacks mais quand ça rendait pas
contre moi ça m'a fait ça ça me fait
seul
ça me fait seules ou est-ce que ça fait
deux semaines que je veux pas c'est dans
le nord que je mets mon c'est l'envoi
d'avions de chars puis j'ai réalisé que
j'avais ce avec moins constamment qui
est une pression constante dans l'est
depuis les huit dernières années que
j'ai deux mots j'ai gardé longtemps un
blackberry pote pas de pôle internet là
pendant longtemps le tiff et que tu
arrives et jeanne tort dans l'iphone
game le mettons le iphone 6 le puits
mais depuis que j'ai ce qu'un jeune et
un pic raillé le pic et ça existe dans
ma vie depuis que j'ai réalisé
dernièrement que cache de fermer puis je
me concentrais sur ça va faire cheesy
mais sur le moment
puis que je t'ai pas ailleurs on attend
être me trompe qui avait même pas la
pensée que peut-être je pourrais
d'ailleurs parce qu'il est en mode avion
fait que j' ai pas cru mes textos fait
que c'est sûr que y'a rien à voir si je
vous montre l'apport leur mettons le lot
j'ai réalisé que j'avais un problème
mais c'est tellement une belle
illustration qu'est-ce que tu viennes
d'écrire de la manière dont ces
appareils sont basés sur un système
économique ou en fait d'ici là on va
faire le lien ensemble mais comme est
premièrement le fait que la déconnexion
le sentiment le soulagement que tu
ressens le ca a été démontré aussi j'ai
vu vous aviez su sonia lupien le bien
non à la cites c'était c'est la
meilleure femme au monde nous parlait
d'une étude où on a fait des cons on a
demandé à des individus de mettre leurs
téléphones de fermer par téléphone puis
au bout de trois semaines on voyait que
la cortisol l'hormone du stress dans
leur sang était descendu qu'il a en
effet tu le décris pourquoi on a moins d
des personnes qui nous écrivent à tout
moment il ya moyen aussi juste la
possibilité de l'utiliser et cetera on
se concentre sur autre chose
le rythme est plus lent puis le système
économique au maillet fait en ce moment
c'est on valorise beaucoup la
productivité puis la productivité puis
le fait de si on pouvait travailler
notre modèle capitaliste on fait
travailler 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 le sacré mais parce que il ya tout le
temps quelque chose qui se passe puis il
ya tout le temps de travail qui se fait
à des mails à l'heure du japon du ctif
toutes les fusées ares répond à des
courriels fait que le système économique
qui bénéficie leur productivité
mais ce rendu que même nos dents non et
non relations dans nos moments de
distraction
on pense comme ça aussi je viens de
recevoir
je trouve dans celui-ci pts 8 ans en
mode productif productive
il faudrait que je réponde intel a mis
en ce moment je fais rien de mon temps
que je pourrais faire une story montré
que je vis et en ce moment j'écris âgées
des courriels qui sont rentrés c'est
tout le système de notification qui le
fait et d'être tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps disponible est
joignable
c'est comme si on avait juste des heures
ouverte de bureau tout le temps
constamment pour nos amis puissent pas
passer nos amis et notre famille que
faut pas se mettre des limites fixes
donc c'est sale c'est de se demander où
est ce que moi je veux mettre des
limites que je m'accorde et des vacances
des jeux
j'ai quelque chose à ceux la
productivité en train la productivité ça
veut dire que moi je suis droit parce
que avec les médias sociaux ces derniers
temps chaud comme dans une espèce de
2,40 absente le paradis plus l'enfant à
l'égard de purgatoire je commente les
deux georges j'aime je sais pas
qu'est-ce que alexandre champagne mois
legault j'ai adoré
ouais j'ai comme rien à dire à travers
la fondation j'ai eu un paquet
d'affaires à dire mais moi
personnellement mon compte instagram 130
quelque 1000 personnes qui me suivent
comme pourquoi j'ai ça il faudrait que
je mens il faudrait commencer avantage
et pas vraiment envie de m'en servir
fait que je fais dit stories aa je monte
je fais du ski genre du touring parce
que je sais que si je fais pas ça
pendant deux semaines puis que lot de
coups je parle ce message pour la
fondation
ça va tomber après y'a pas en crise de
choc et volvo sauf que moi
personnellement j'ai rien à dire
maintenant je suis dans une période de
ma vie où est ce que j'écoute j'écoute
je réfléchis je prends des longues
marches à rien faire je reste sur mon
sofa j'atteins je parle avec médium
j'essaie évoqué une place vraiment ma
vie présentement j'ai des projets
pilotes
je travaille mais la majorité du temps
c'est banal c'est vraiment c'est vrai la
benne j'entends ce que tu dis puis je le
ressens aussi le mot j'ai plus que les
lorraines manques sont le si je pense
que la pandémie à accélérer le processus
de cette réflexion la fecq le tu dis là
qu'il joue une connexion avec les gens
clairement avoir la connexion est que
les gens se développe d'abord de
l'effervescence que si j'ai pas
d'effervescence je vois comme est oublié
puis doute si un feeling qui épaulent
fans c'est de te sentir peau valide de
te sentir pas vu ou d'être sentir pas
considérer puis le fed est absent sur
les réseaux sociaux qui reste beaucoup
parce qu'il faut que ce soit présent
pour générer de la découvrabilité puis
générique du monde qui vous même t
écoute j'ai fait des tests comme les
amis proches en scholes
j'ai mis un paquet personnes j'en ai pas
fait qu'ils jouent mais surtout à des
reçus j'ai comme 30 personnes là dessus
j'ai choisi des gens en fait j'ai le
même âge prédit la limite les shojo
acheter les seules personnes qui vont
dans mes amis proches et les gens qui
ont déjà vu mes enfants
et quand je met enfin le gendre avec
sauna considèrent comme la fuite puis
j'ai fait un test puis même les amis
proches facebook tof professe bobin oui
facebook le papa par association
d'instagram de force en faire quand même
parce que je me souviens que quand je
mettais une story amis proches cent pour
cent des gens qui est analysé amis
proches les voiliers puis le récemment
ça faisait longtemps que je n'avais pas
mis j'en ai mis une à c'est comme la
moitié ces chiffres pour nous sommes
encore l'islande cette fois les vidéos
des enfants que je mets des fields
snapshot de supplice à leurs fins de
voix grave fillon est l'adoré parce
qu'on les exploite littéralement moment
qui ce contenu le bo le sa maman je veux
dire le choix mais t'as pas le choix de
faire tous les simagrées possible
pourtant favori - comme gros flash je
t'écris d'êtres humains je regarde
l'historique des fois que j'ai délita
président parce que ge com c'est un
signe c'est d'une insignifiance capitale
ça aucun hosties bon sens que j'ai
autant d'enfants dans ma vraie vie qui
ce qui est pas instagram ans que je
mette pas du temps là dessus comme une
présence à ma fille m'a tant que que je
n'ai pas de sympathie que je mets des
dystopies james au phare du skip du
tourime même année quand ça fait
quarante photos mon choix de skis et ski
on sacralise donné le petit je suis
extrêmement sauf quand je le suis c'est
chouette ce paramètre avec tout le monde
qui me suis je sais pas ce que je fais
en soit j'ai windows comme à londres où
j'avais des votes des tonnes je fais
mais je dois juste faire un album tu vas
chercher mais moi j'ai une question
puisque c'est une vraie question est ce
que c'est un problème des personnes
publiques telle escalade
non mais dans ce sens oui mais est-ce
que c est ce qu est ce qu on parle à
nous autres mais qu'est ce que le commun
des mortels vi a promis à ses clubs à ce
que l'utilisateur moyen instagram
recensé pression-là de porter tout le
temps de danisco new soul ou sont justes
présents puissent et sa descendance des
arrêtés qui entre une fois on revient
aux difficultés personnelles si je
quelqu'un qui a besoin de validation
social que j'aime ça être vu et je la
personne qu'on est dans une soirée
d'amis comme en et je ressens le besoin
de parler plus fort que tout le monde
faire mon show parce que j'aime cette
revue qui malheureusement sept personnes
le même si elle pas un gros c'est
beaucoup de personnes qui la suit et oui
à votre tête ressentir ce une autre
personne qui s'en fou qui a pas besoin
de se montrer aux autres à vivre open
samantha stress là comme il ya des
personnalités publiques des sites de
jambes à moi j'ai pas de médias sociaux
pis voilà c'est ça ça m'importe peu
mais oui ça va toucher des personnes
normales maintenant si je pars de mon
cas personnel jusque là décision de
n'est pas pour ces personnes normales on
lit tous les deux liés aux actes et qui
n'ont pas des gens qui les suivent puis
québec sainte à gaza
non mais vimont mais tout ce que je
trouvais d'ici là avis c'est justement
comme tu dis maintenant je fais du ski
est ce que je le publie ou peu pourquoi
j'aime publie comme moi c'est paul ii
puis j'ai prédictions justes pas posté à
moindre frais comme besoin d'être
juste pour info inga sud met donc le
droit de pouvoir toujours dire qu'est ce
que je tenterai une fine est trop lourd
à porter je me suis juste comme une
limite de nom jean jé publierait peu qui
sait des personnes dont je suis qui
peuvent se reconnaître la dalle de comme
julien mathon des méfiances et j'ai le
public je dis pas ça moi personnellement
je me suis pas fait mais maintenant j'ai
une méfiance et j'ai le plus petit je
publie dessus ou peu si jean g kg
mettons 400 amis facebook mais toutes
mes copines ils l'ont fait parce que moi
faut que je fasse comme un pôle qte qui
l'achète en cinq chevaux dessus au bout
de trois mois que je mets des blocs a
peur que j'écrive je serai ni dans six
mois
les gens y vivent quand même la personne
est qui qui en a pas de fiançailles
picards n'ont pas de bébé qui arrive à
le dire mon dieu moi je pense que rien
je devrais tu au moins montré que j'ai
une vie même si jusqu'à un pic et
s'entendent pas d'avoir des enfants
tu es donc oui c'était cette pression là
et se transpose ses succès à l'open même
impact
oui c'est lui qui j'aime qui parle de se
vendre jusqu'à près d'annecy aux jeux
pense que vous l'avez reçu au patriat
vous devriez recevoir jusqu'à pris
d'assaut elle a gagné au gala dynastie
récemment personnalités world engagé de
l'année je crois puis au galet mammoth
aussi pour à peu près la même catégorie
le nom exact m'échappe mais jusqu'à
mettait des cerises ou allait faire une
publication quand steve avant la fin de
l'année père dit et tout le monde a eu
l'idée achieve mène pendant l'année tout
le monde a eu des ddd chose
d'extraordinaire que vous n'êtes pas
obligé de faire de gaffe on s'en fout
dans le fond je trouve que des personnes
comme ça c'est important sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est moins ce qu
emmanuel ze je trouvais ça trop lourd à
porter le fait de devoir toujours montré
ce que je fais enfin que j'ai juste
arrêté de le faire ça me fait comme du
bien l'entendre c'est pas que je le
savais pas que c'est juste que j'avais
besoin de validation peut-être dans cet
aspect de ma vie est ce que ça veut dire
que je vais quitter les réseaux sociaux
non mais présentement ma réflexion par
exemple on revient à des gens un pan de
la vie qui est publiquement sans tache
pour véronique faut-il six mois j'ai
beaucoup été connue par je faisais des
photos de ma fille quand tu vois sur mon
nom sur google chez l'ex à marilou fixé
jusqu'à pas de reconnaître que je suis
peut-être un f loti maton qui a b c d e
f g les venelles non non mais c'est quoi
cette gradation complètement tu
comprends je connais ma vie je connais
ma valeur je connais mes mimiques
habituelles mais pour en revenir à sauce
c'est ça c'est que j'ai une grande
remise en question par rapport s'appuie
il ya beaucoup de gens que ce que quand
je précise que ce que j'ai commencé à
faire le tissage la partie je dis
souvent manu les réseaux sociaux cds
plateforme pour s'exprimer
c'est pas des plateformes qui sont
conçus pour écouter vraiment et je me
suis ici changement 27
il ya beaucoup d'entrepreneurs instagram
dès qu'ils sont tout le temps comme seul
geste
washing machine cie de change de mindset
sully quatre heures par jour 6 1
millions à 3 h 30 c'était un col en bref
je pense que si on se met dans un état
de droit parce que j'ai fait la même
chose pour la photographie au début je
faisais de la photographie pour montrer
ce que j'avais photographié des chèques
ce que j'ai photographié
maintenant je fais de la photographie
parce que j'ai envie d'écouter ce que
les gens ont à dire juste un prétexte
pour avoir une conversation puis c'est
un prétexte aussi pour prêter toute la
visite et que j'ai eue grâce au pogo que
j'ai photographié pour donner une voix
du monde qui en ont moins mon
contestation s'est rendu ce j'écoute
pendant de la cloche dans leurs débuts
chez des gens à leur poste et sauf que
je suis blanc man puis je sais pas c'est
quoi les enjeux que les noirs ont beau
du tout même chose pour les victimes
d'agressions sexuelles
même chose pour les communautés
marginalisées je sais pas fait que par
exemple aujourd'hui la journée
internationale des droits de la femme
on est le 8 mars pour le lot génie c'est
possible aujourd'hui on remarque jean
petit bout mais c'est ça qui l'a jeté
comme art qu'est ce que je pourrais dire
pour les pour l'âge pleuvent j'ai fait
non non non qu'est ce que je pourrais
écouter
qu'est ce que je pourrais apprendre ta
gueule puis apprend parce que je prends
une femme je suis beaucoup je suis au
courant des enjeux des femmes et je peux
juste imaginer fait pour moi c'est
devenu plus une plate forme d' écoute
pis c'est comme une relation
dichotomique parce que j'ai envie
d'aider à faire parce que des fois j'ai
besoin d'attention une validation comme
tout le monde c'est un autre niveau
parce que j'ai des blessures d'enfance
qui sont là
mais je pense que ça doit devenir où on
doit faire en sorte que des individus
s'en servent aussi à un niveau égal
comme une plante fois une plateforme
pour écouter et gesca prédation signifie
que j'ai découvert
grâce à cela il ya plein de monde que
j'ai découvert grâce à ce puits se
trouve que c'est fantastique pour ça et
c'est un peu pour ça que j'ai qu'on a
mis la fondation sur pied puis qu'on
continue à développer c'est qu'il ya dix
ans
on croit énormément au pouvoir positif
mais à condition qu'on change notre
monde on trouve qu'on change de 37 par
rapport à comment on utilise ces gens
bien quoi ça
mettons mettons ce qu'il m'avait dit
j'ai allégé sa a ajouté que l'ordre est
je me sens mal pour les personnes qui
veulent poster pour de revalidation
c'est correct ça c'est moi j'ai pris
c'est bon j'ai pris sa décision là par
exemple maison j'avais et j'ai un ami
qui traversait un break up qui est
estimé à foule publier des story
directement après parce que bon avec
comme si court qu'il ait des photos
relations justes des c'est juste de la
shdm et s'est dit conscient de ce que tu
fais de comac isolé en ce moment j'ai un
manque affectif je veux développer des
relations dans des fréquentations fait
que je fais des story juste pour ce coup
qui un jour j'ai besoin ici je me sens
vraiment mal je vais appeler mon ami
manu puis on va en jaser puis on va se
parler on va aller prendre une marche
mais en ce moment j'ai besoin d'un petit
peu si le mot clé je mens je pense que
tu as 10 et je pensais peut-être ce mot
là c'est le faire consciemment noté
inconscient de la relation qu'on est que
les réseaux sociaux puissent avoir une
relation super intense et symbiotique
des réseaux sociaux mais si tu fait
consciemment tu es capable de
d'artillerie positif sans trop négative
d'un trident fond il n'y a pas de
problème de versus mais des fois j'ai
l'impression que cette réalisation le
s'installe justement comme quand même
une relation toxique ou est-ce que tout
est beau début qui est finalement il ya
des flaques et ignoble camani prennent
toute la place piqué finalement t'es
juste problème était tellement données
collectées vous a pu le dire justement
ces questions pour téléphone une fin de
semaine
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu ce
que ça fait c'est que le tu prends un
step back un peu de recul quand tu
reviens dans les oueds flag des voies
plus rapidement en attaque et qui pour
quoi que faire quand je trouve mon celle
de tout d'un coup j'ai une boule dans le
ventre ce type ce célèbre sa rencontre 4
alors pris un steve balmer et ses
boutons pourquoi j'ai les boules en
cassation belge en moins en moins j'ai
vraiment moins en moins parce que
justement
je pense maintenant là dessus je pense
avoir moins de temps là-dessus je passe
mon temps à juste telle espèce de moment
où est ce que comme toute chaude dans le
titre et ont vite fait je souscris au
lit comme un samedi n'était vraiment
arrêter ce justement le tp tipi dans la
conscience du moment présent
l'absence totale c est après ceux qui
travaillent à qui ça fait une demi heure
et une heure que je fais si tu sais ça
sans avoir vu le temps passé sans qu'il
est et qui sait avant le foot et il
avait des journées j'avais des arts qui
disparaissait maintien j'avais beaucoup
trop de temps que disparaissait comme ce
pilot maintenant je ferai plus attention
à ce marathon vraiment beaucoup plus
saine avec ceux qui s'essaient au
piquant je suis dessus j'ai c'est d'être
conscient de ce que je fais pas juste
comme tomber les espèces de tomates six
minutes s'écoulent que tu parles de
conscience deux affaires premier enfant
tu dis les réseaux sociaux comme une
relation toxique
au début tout va bien pour mener
tranquillement pas vite de façon
insidieuse d'une blague
arrive le problème les réseaux sociaux
c'est que c'est comme ça mais que à
chaque fois que tu arrives pour flaguais
red flag et la plate forme change pour
françois que c'est plus un réflexe nunzi
comme du corps est une pratique qui est
normal c'est du gros gaz lighting c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que
l'utilisateur
un sentiment qui est pas correct
commence à prendre action sur ce
sentiment le plus haut
la plate forme change pour avoir un
autre comportement qui est pas correct
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à temps que tu
t'adresses à thé vulnérabilité
psychologique
une des manières de le faire c'est avec
la pleine conscience c'est un un
mouvement ou un principe qui devient de
plus en plus populaire la pleine
conscience important parce que comme tu
dis si tu es conscient de la manière
dont on utilise les médias sociaux
ça vaut tdi sauf qu'il faut aussi qu'ils
soient conscients et informé de la
manière dont les réseaux sociaux
fonctionnent aussi donc temps de se
demander c'est quoi l'objectif mais
l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
les actions qui sont entreprises par les
plateformes qui créent les réseaux
sociaux soit le plus transparent
possible parce que si tu veux prendre
action sur des choses encore faut-il que
tu comprennes comme à ces choses ne
fonctionnent si je te donne un charme
qui sait pas comment ça marche
même si changer super bien fait c'est un
équilibre entre les deux qu'on essaie
d'atteindre mes mais je trouve que le
mot conscience y est extrêmement bien
choisis dans ce comté pitt c'est aussi
le symbole
dans le ventre le qu'on pourrait
peut-être appeler le stress le
tristement ses soigneurs le déconstruit
rappelé les racines des sources de
stress le type il y en a quatre
béton 2 6 4 le viendrait sceller
gonthier illégaux ça fait une grosse
partie du truc je pense chamakh les
réseaux sociaux parce que la comparaison
est excessivement présente tout regard
d'un tel pour que lui et c'est pourquoi
lui est plus que simple cueilli conson
un nombre que lui plus d'efforts hors
satan dans lego donc c'est une source de
stress presse le sentiment d'avoir de
sentiment de perte de contrôle des
palois de contrôle de votre contrôle sur
six que les autres publics votre
contrôle aussi sur pc aussi linus est
aussi l'information les nouvelles
réseaux sociaux ti cats et tout le temps
puis c'est sonia lisez moi je regarde
plus du coupé les nouvelles depuis je me
tiens plus loin les réseaux sociaux ce
flot constant là sur des choses externe
à toi sur les quelques pas de contrôler
ces sources une source de stress
ouais tiens en étant consciente de ce
résultat m'a t'on comme aujourd'hui je
me serais riche s'est lui dit je t'aime
plus fatigués c'est la journée 20 ans
elle défend et battante que des droits
des femmes que je commence à regarder ce
puisque eux george hill goût je me sens
pas une parole et je me rappelle encore
que je suis avantagé alors que j'aurais
pu être un autre moment dans mon cycle
menstruel qui est vraiment gentillesse
let's go girls ont publié des photos
jaunies faire des femmes nana mais
aujourd'hui ce matin c'était poste
sachant que comme tu dis on sait pas sur
quoi on tombe que ce matin je tombe ces
médias sociaux puis je me sens mal à
bien qu'ils jouent aux polices utilisées
aujourd'hui je veux les aider mais ils
ont un nom de matin que tom le goût de
motivation qui était besoin d'un feu
mais reste par yvon l'île maurice que
ces problèmes il m'apparaît là le
problème apparaît de justement pas être
conscient de thiais mettons que tout les
jours tu le trait de la même façon parce
que tu te rends pas compte de la
vulnérabilité ctobre et des jours qui ça
va juste un médiateur c'est quand même
atteint ici toi tu pleures petit peu
garde de réaliser que t'es pas capable
de prendre conscience qu'aujourd'hui tu
fais le pas pour se situe à regarde
quand même tu t'exposes à ça quand même
moi ça m'a fait ça personnellement
pendant les
la vague de dénonciations sur sur
instagram ou est ce qu'elle est et rendu
juste parce que tout le monde le faisait
jeter rendu abonné aux pages des
dénonciations de tout le monde puisque
je t'ai semonce est là chaque matin je
me levais tchèque un bon qui sait qu'il
accepte le s'était rendu à un réflexe
peut ramener à mais on sent par les
autres chez nous on était les deux
quatre partiront nicolas comté d'un
appart à comme une semaine à être coach
est là dessus ça n'a pas de bon sens
peut lire des témoignages sans pitié je
veux dire on est loin d'être à plaindre
parce qu'on est pas difficile nous
manque juste juste l'effet que les
réseaux sociaux onu sur nous on était
complètement pas bien ils l'ont été
c'est la seule chose qui existe elle
existe et ça met toute la place pie ix
ont ils quelque chose ça c'est qu'on
commande on sentait step woleu-ntem
non mais mais mais mais si je veux
acheter que ces fonds n'a pas choisi
aussi de la vérité en face c'est ce que
je veux dire en france que j'aime
beaucoup qui disent et par le feu qu'on
éprouve lors de paul choix de forget
puis de taper sur du métal pour que ça
devienne un bijou éventuellement je
pense pileux mais ce parce qu'une fois
que tu apprennes après deux trois jours
d'au dessus
j'avais compris le ticket qui est
l'auteur avec moi mettons mon ma
réaction personnelle aurait pu être
bloqués le tchèque
c'est un bon mouvement car il est
important mais le mois jugent aussi
qu'il entame et les réflexions comme se
remettre en question je fais ce que
j'aime avec sa gérer etc
c'est cette continuité des réflexions
mettait un besoin de besoin de moments
de retrait mais sans exception
l'affection qu'ils sont faciles mais
agréable à voir mais qui sont
nécessaires mais l'espace quitter on
appose un mouvement qui ticket qui
disent pas nécessaire à l'entité qui
s'écrit sur des réseaux sociaux puis
henri l'autre son pot contre attaque
c'est au dessus
c'est la réaction que nous appartient
tantôt alex disait quelque chose
était en relation les dix sept grammes
sont initialement une plateforme pour
parler tout je te souhaitons mindset
pour dire que c'est une plateforme pour
écouter mois ci dans cette dichotomie là
que j'ai un problème extrêmement
persistant avec les réseaux sociaux ou
est-ce que j'ai l'impression que du
moins dans mon expérience les lieux de
communication de partager des coups tout
est ce que les deux sont intrinsèques
c'est là que naît c'est les meilleurs
réflexion les meilleures puces de 2 pour
nous faire grandir en fait
puis la dichotomie en soit ces
pourparlers au souci pour écouter j'ai
l'impression qu'un problème là j'ai
l'impression que moss qui manque dans le
paysage médiatique que tanner qui le
paysage médiatique pour des gens de
notre âge c'est c'est surtout des les
médias sociaux en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'il manque juste un espace de dialogue
oui vraiment et puis il ya des
recherches qui prouve que depuis
l'abolition en fait pas l'abolition mais
la disparition des rendez vous à
l'église puis la diminution en
popularité de la religion du des
regroupements du fait des piges je dis
pas que la région c'est la meilleure
chose le ça a été extrêmement pressante
ce pendant des milliers d'années la
religion seuls encore ça l'est encore
pour certaines régions du globe
mais le fait d'avoir la foi le fait
d'appartenir à un groupe le fait de
savoir qui était peu spécial qui est
beaucoup de monde qui vont être affectés
par des décisions c'est super important
le problème encore une fois savions
modèle économique on a dit aux gens
maintenant on voit maintenant une
plateforme gohan c'est comme vols de tu
es pro présente pas comme robin c'est
vraiment aidé à une formation de comme
avant quand tu t'inscris sur facebook
faut que tu ailles passer ta fille
l'autre sujet pour savoir comme argument
telus l'apologie de ce club
l'allégorie de la caverne ces photos
elle fait des enfants parce qu'il ya le
contexte des médias sociaux vie ce à
différents niveaux mais pour avoir un
espace où on dialogues piquants converse
de manière civilisée il encore faut-il
savoir et débattre de manière
respectueuse qui a cette partie le piler
l'environnement numérique nous incite
potes il ya pas une indication ou
voulez-vous ajouté merci à la fin de
votre message comme la plateforme est
pas fait pour qu'on soit pour toi
courtois avec les services ça dépend de
ton système de valeur puisse vraiment
drôle j'ai commencé à écouter la série
dark sur netflix puisqu'ils cause dans
la série dark le chi désolé c'est des
gens qui l'ont pas vu et écouté moins
pas pour le pour le reste je veux donner
d'espoir mais il ya trois périodes
temporelles 1953 1986 puis 2019 puis
j'ai ce qui m'a fait le plus hallucinant
la série autre que la cinématographie le
scénario la qualité des personnages
c'est le fait que les moeurs et coutumes
dans les années 50
versus de 20 19 comment les personnages
se comportent les uns avec les autres
l'enjeu des personnages là la teneur en
lourdeur des motions des personnages en
2019 est complètement différente de
celle de 1950 euros dans toutes les
scènes qui se passent en 1953 et de la
courtoisie
ok il ya de la galanterie qui a dû vient
dire bonjour merci j'espère que je boxe
cuse moi je pense avoir le gspr les gens
sont conscients de l'impact qu'ils ont
sur les autres aujourd'hui au maine il
ya quelque chose qui a disparu il ya ce
respect l'oeil ya cette étiquette le qui
a disparu on est accessible tout le
temps on est souvent représentations sur
les médias sociaux puis je trouve ça
vraiment important de faire la
distinction
justement là dedans parce que ça m'a
marqué dans cette série d'objets
réalisés hier on a vu la finale puis
jetée comme omagad il manque de
politesse et de courtoisie pissos est
exacerbée par la par la polarisation
d'ailleurs est ce que tu penses que ça
le disparu des réactions physiques ou
seulement sur la soirée très tôt sociaux
je pars réseaux sociaux je pense que
dans l'aspect physique moi c'est écouter
et ça l'est entre les années 50
j'appelle souvent les gens monseigneur
j'ai l'impression que il ya vraiment une
grosse différence entre les interactions
qu'on a en face à face à un vrai et sur
les réseaux sociaux
parce que tu es admettons tu viens ici
ou si vous venez ici on parle ce n'est
pas d'accord on va essayer de trouver un
terrain d'entente ont été de parler j'en
ai déjà parlé sur le podcast n'ai parlé
avec cornet qui est venu témoin germany
j'ai fait
j'argumente pas que les gens sur les
réseaux sociaux je n'ai pas mon énergie
mon temps là dedans parce que je pense
que c'est extrêmement rare qu'on va
arriver à un terrain d'entente piqué
l'autre voudra mais trouve à la crise
les lis des pics ont vraiment essayé de
nuances et de nos propos c'est souvent
tac tac tac des opinions ce pas tranchée
qui s'écoute poche et 2002 monologue
chacun son côté parce qu'il connaît en
vrai on est beaucoup plus conscients de
l'impact qu'on ne puisse si je te dis
quelque chose qui te blesses fn fasse je
veux m'excuser si j'arrive à eau à
l'épicerie
je veux dire merci à madame parce que
parce que ça doit il faire plaisir ils
pensent que parce que je suis content
que les gamins servi j'ai l'impression
que c'est juste que tous ses réflexes le
puits toutes ses sphères lors du non
verbal puis de l'espèce de peu des games
et d'espèces de d'interactions qui est
normal anduze moins d'essayer de sap
recipe trouver un commun accord sous les
huées et thomas évacué parce que de
pâles à répondre aux personnes que je
peux insulter j'aurais jamais le
contrecoup de l'insulté est envoyée mais
pas juste ça il ya aussi la manière dont
interprète le temps de l'autre personne
dépend uniquement de tes références
socioculturel effective si toi dans ta
vie tu es tu un jour donner un exemple
xleu mais si toi tu as vite a eu un père
qui est extrêmement sévère puis qui
s'opposaient à toutes les idées qui se
pose est à tes valeurs où a été désertée
en vie dès qu'il va y avoir la
confrontation
c'est comme ça tu va percevoir la
confrontation pilotes se battent bas
tropiques la personne méritante concept
de valeur ou langeree d'alice
c'est con à dire mais je sais que je
peux trouver des psys des neuro psycho
vont qui vont approuver ce que je suis
en train de dire c'est que tu été
déclenchée par un symbole qui tu réagis
à ce symbole de tout le temps parce que
ça vienne de ton amygdales quittant
voiture comme côté en danger
présentement petite voix sur réagir à ce
qui est en train de se passer alors que
la personne méchante reine de dire qu on
devrait pas laisser entrer des
immigrants ainsi c'est correct on peut
penser ce que tu veux c'est pas grave
mais il ya énormément de données
d'études scientifiques des données
empiriques des choses comme ça qui nous
prouve que l'immigration est un bénéfice
à notre système mais pourquoi titre ce
n'est qu'un gars ou une fille que tu
connais pas qui habite à 300 km de chez
vous ou qui habitent en haute chez toi
ou petits aviez de où il vient d où ce
désir leurs besoins de l'affecter pas
capable de sortir de sa part après les
médias sociaux ça uniquement rapport
avec ta manière de gérer cette situation
le prix sar rapport aussi avec les
médias si un enfant assez difficile
d'imaginer les médias sociaux autrement
que la manière dont sont construits
aujourd'hui telle interface mais
imaginons que bon nous deux on se pose
là dessus d'une conversation le thé
c'est exactement pour prendre mais la
plateforme continue nous envoyer des
notifications de comme acquis étaient
personnes ont répondu à ton commentaire
et pourrait ouvrir à qui vous avez été
comme le wiz le sur msn jadis ne pouvait
pas envoyer plusieurs with de suivi de
la plateforme tête des candidats
ces gens 3 with max après mon bloc on
pourrait dire qu'il vous avait envoyé
deux messages chaque appelez-vous par ce
système par messenger vous avez et ça va
être un appel pivot numéros sont coupées
mais encore une fois la plateforme à
vous renvoyer à ne pas de convertir par
un appel téléphonique qui va au dessus
donc mes images
imaginons mais je reçois jamais reçu de
message d'un sucre mais jallet ses
matons quelqu'un qui écrit le
commentateur force et ce quelque chose
par le corvec sopi et et est ainsi parti
10e j'aurais juste envie de répondre
allez on s'appelle du genre on va
s'expliquer et puis j'ai vraiment
l'impression qui est comme tout de suite
mais oui ça a tout changé et est pascal
quand j'ai dit ce que je voulais vous
dire ce pinot note expliquant quand tu
gagnes en charge quelqu'un plati fini
par baisser afin de sortir de l'auto
plaît il ya comme une rencontre désolé
je t'ai cesse parce que je pensais que
j'allais tourner puis c'est vrai non non
non c'est ma force et ma ça m'est arrivé
on savait à gorge pour on avait chacun
anglais d'ailleurs j'ai une question sur
la fondation dans le fond votre mission
on la comprend de plus en plus et sont
aussi mais c'est comme ça c'est quoi la
manière dont vous agissez mettons
mettons mettons moi je me sens pas mais
je vous appelle le sait que commencer
son personnel conséquent ce qu'il a la
mission la fondation fait attention
c'est pas en intervention c'est de la
prévention et de la sensibilisation la
prévention ainsi que dans les écoles
secondaires on a une atelier qui monte
pour les jeunes de 14 à 17 ans et selon
à 3,5
donc là on fait là on a touché des
peines plus de 1000 jeunes en février et
sait pas quand on travaille à ce niveau
là en prévention avec les jeunes classe
par classe du haut niveau c'est la
sensibilisation jeu à temps c'est
tellement intéressant
cette partie là de ce qu'on fait parce
que on a pris les ateliers d'un
organisme qui s'appelle bien-être
numérique on a voulu fusionner parce que
quand j'ai fondé seul
quand j'ai eu l'idée de la fondation je
voulais qu'on donne des ateliers puis
emmanuel faisait partie du conseil
d'administration de l'organisme
bien-être numérique ça existait des jeux
puis moi je suis pas capable de me
mettre un esprit de compétition dans vie
je prie je prends mon sérieux je me met
en rage avait une course à faire et
colibri most était en vélo je me ravit
si je me mets en rire puis je dois bien
je veux un spectateur sur ce trouble
fois d'un spectateur sur votre faim fait
bref je me suis dit on devrait utiliser
ce et lorsqu'on afin d'enfoncer qu'on a
eu on a changé un petit peu la formule
on a changé la présentation on ne
trouvait plus de présentateurs on a
quand même mis un système là on a mis
des ressources à disposition de biens
numériques puis ce qu'on entend des ados
c'est très loin de ce que les médias
nous disent et les adultes nous disent
des ados ouais pas ce qui est important
dans cet atelier là c'est qu'elle est un
atelier qui s'appelle autodéfense
numérique puis qui démystifie d'effet
sur le numérique donc on vit aujourd'hui
à l'époque de la super dépendance mon
téléphone intelligent membres anticipé
de les médias sociaux de rendre
dépressif ont des choses à donner comme
qu'ils ont dansé pilon on anime une
discussion avec les ados et ensuite on
fait un retour avec les faits
scientifiques l'attitude du camp même on
est fiers le seul les mettant la
perception des autres on a la perception
que les ados sont nullement
cyberdépendants comparaison constante
concours de popularité sur la réalité ou
ses passes à l'arrêter
j'ai goûté demander quand on a une
réflexion comme ça tu vas faire douce et
est maintenant cette impression le bâtir
douze imams et en perspective le même
temps je l'aï tiré cette conclusion là
de com de mon expérience à moins de
comment je le vis maintenable de comment
je le vivrais si j'étais si j'étais un
adolescent transpose enduite et avoir
grandi d'ex entre les mains si son ultra
connectés on imagine que ce qui se passe
c'est justement une sur sur connexion ne
des réseaux sociaux mais parce que c'est
faux est-ce que c'est faux ce que c'est
vrai que c'est faux est ce qu est ce que
cette génération là et plus anxieuse et
plus justement déprimé et plus ou non
est ce qu'ils savent gérer mieux la
sociaux voient bien c'est vraiment
difficile
il ya plusieurs choses là-dedans un
comparé aux ados eux ils disposent ils
vont pas pointer les médias sociaux
comme un problème dans leur vie plus
ennuyeux que c'est un outil comme quand
est ce comme si j'avais eu un atelier à
mon école secondaire qui venaient me
parler genre du l'impact de la télé sur
l'image corporelle j'en étais capable
j'aurais jamais dit que la télé est un
problème - ce pour quoi j'avais mes
cheveux frisés et puis que je trouvais
que j'avais un gros ventre mais
maintenant avec du recul
capable de voir qu'il y avait une
influence la représentation télévisuelle
à l'époque quand j'avais 14 ans c'est un
peu la même chose on va peut on avait un
problème dont éclaté on l'a vu avec le
documentaire de britney spears le on
enfin je sais pas pourquoi j'ai parlé le
montre aujourd'hui c'est la même chose
pour les ados ils savent qu'il ya des
problèmes d'intimidation et ses amis
vont pas pointer les médias sociaux
exactement ils vont parler avec leurs
amis ni là dessus et cetera ils sont
conscients quand même des enjeux du fait
qu il ya des inconnues la tuque il faut
juste que que l'intimidation qu'il faut
faire attention qu'il faut gérer son
image etc
ce sont conscients ensuite si on parle
d'étudier une génération en génération
on a fait une conférence avec léger
léger marketing qui fait une étude
génère sur la génération des milléniaux
puis la génération au cm qui les ados
présentement puis oui on voit que les
jeunes sont plus anxieux mais et que la
norme 15 manquantes dans la vente dans
la vingtaine du moins c'est d'être
anxieux et épices pressé maintenant
c'est difficile depuis j'ai pas la
réponse est difficile de dire que c'est
juste la faute aux écrans télé on est
aussi dans une société où on est super
exigeant et la n6 toute une société qu
une culture de performance
les jeunes oignons normand de la
pression pour avoir des bons résultats à
l'école et que cette erreur avec l'aco
vide laissé dans le tapis non mais c'est
pas que je n'ai pas de réponse mais qui
toujours dit je viendrai dans un atelier
le pitre se retirait vraiment optimiste
parce que les jeunes sont conscients
sont intelligents sont capables d de
pointe et ce qui m'a t'on fait exquis
ivre et esquisse pillon encore il ya
encore toute la candeur que ça prend
pour adresser des enjeux avec la
bienveillance puis ça c'est quelque
chose c'est une ressource le
devrait on devrait canaliser l'appui on
devrait passer ce qu'on veut devenir un
catalyseur d'espoir envers les
générations qui s'en viennent je veux
vraiment parce que on a l'impression que
l'on nomme tous les problèmes et si on
se dit est ce que c'est vrai que les
jeunes sont plus anxieux mou je me suis
ma première crise de panique j'avais 18
ans j'ai dix ans mes parents qui étaient
comme mode doute fatigué aujourd'hui je
dirais à mes parents j'ai fait une crise
de panique frais comme au hockey
ben là il prend pas parce qu'ils
prenaient pas au sérieux puisque c'était
pas culturellement connu accepté
discuter et puis tout le travail qui a
été fait sur les réseaux sociaux
d'éducation face à la santé mentale
c'est extrêmement important
on est on est on a pris un raccourci
vers des manières de les choisir de
s'auto traiter parce que nous nous nos
instances de santé ont de la difficulté
à gérer la demande on sait qu'ils lisent
datant de deux ans au public pour voir
nos personnes en soins de santé mentale
ce qui est alarmant parce que les gens
réalisent c'est que les problèmes de
santé mentale mais est-ce que les gens
sont plus stressés moi je pense qu'on a
juste réaliser qu'ils ont les tn ue et
c'est difficile de vivre sur une planète
aussi que le tiers du monde mange pas
jeudi
or qui s'éteint on avait vision mondiale
pour nous le rappeler le coach quand je
te fumer mais comme c'est ça pareil dit
moi je ne dis pas que de la difficulté à
dormir au règlement empêche pas de bien
vivre parce qu'il ya des enjeux sur le
globe mais mais comme c'est étonnant
ça fait chaque petite chose comme ça ça
porte atteinte at on bien là et puis tu
dis ben si moi je suis tellement bien
pourquoi les autres peuvent pas être
aussi bien plus impressionnant on parle
de masse monétaire globale qui était à
qui appartient à un pour cent des gens
sur la terre on sait que c'est pas une
question de manque d'argent on sait que
c'est une question de gestion et
institut facultaire grand chose qui nous
amène à devenir plus stressés surtout
parce qu'on a accès à l'information du
fait que la vie c'est difficile
l'existence et et d'ici là on peut
regarder les auteurs existentialisme
comme jean paul sartre maintenant je me
souviens avoir lu le mur puis ça m'a
pris comme des années à me remettre de
cette affaire là tu sais je trouve ça
tombe bien difficile d'exister g lui
substituer le mandat j'ai fait mon petit
bout de chemin pg j'ai trouvé mon
bonheur à travers certaines affaires
mais on peut pas lier ça directement aux
écrans mais nous les écrans
le numérique c'est un prétexte pour
s'adresser à cette génération-là plafond
comme vous êtes demain puis you comme
une fausse urgence sur les médias
sociaux de toujours être à l'affût de la
du dernier enjeu social ces qui la
personne le plus grand ou la plus grande
guerrière de la vertu alors que les
changements effectués par des personnes
ont un impact des générations plus tard
je parle de martin luther king je parle
de gandhi marc teresa c'est que ces
gens-là de leur vivant était détesté le
ses beautés gens qui auraient eu pas mal
de l'aigle sur instagram si je disais
martin luther king a été assassiné
puis il ya encore des pourparlers comme
quoi ce serait un inside job parce
qu'ils faisaient trop de bruit et puis
je regardais fois la cote de popularité
de martin luther king à cette époque la
6e gala dédié sa vie au complet pour
pour les droits des noirs de la
reconnaissance des droits civils mais
comme c'est aujourd'hui qu'on commence à
reconnaître l'impact fixe pas faisant
impôts sur instagram demain matin sur un
enjeu social qui est idiot magath dont
20 chacun que ça va changer les choses
ça prend un effort concerté
ça prend du temps ça prend vraiment
vraiment beaucoup de temps pour changer
des choses qui nous c'est le premier pas
d'une série de je sais pas combien puis
j'espère que ma fille jane va reprendre
cette idée loeb il va continuer puisque
ces enfants elles vont continuer
continuer moi je pense pas que je vais
avoir un impact significatif de mon
vivant
sur ce mais est il faut commencer
quelque part pis et c'est ce qu'on fait
avec manu si jamais tu disais dans mon
atelier vous à la fin après avoir
discuté ddd des croyances des
perceptions vous revenez avec des faits
scientifiques des statistiques
c'est quoi ces cyclones en béton
grossièrement on en a cinq
mais disons que je suis adressé lui
puisque tu parles d'anxiété et puis des
fois on veut parler aussi de symptômes
dépressifs qu'ils ont à nous parler
aussi son attaque sa g et on va dire est
ce que les médias sociaux vont causer la
dépression ou vont causer de l'anxiété
sociale
il ya plusieurs choses à ce niveau là
les études qui vont nous regarder des
gens et puis bon avec des outils le
démontrer en sciences le pouvoir est ce
que tu as des symptômes dépressifs et
c'est qui c'est quoi le lien qu'on peut
faire avec le temps que tu parles sur
les médias sociaux sans savoir c'est
quoi que tu fais précisément sur les
médias sociaux le mail
dans d'écran de divertissement il ya en
effet un lien avec des personnes qui
passent plus de trois heures par jour
des craintes distraction puis des
symptômes dépressifs
c'est pas de cause à effet ça se peut
que si moi je développe une dépression
puis que je trouve ça de plus en plus
difficile d'aller au travail de voir mes
amis et le soir quand on propose d'aller
prendre un verre dans une vie où on a le
droit sortir d'un bar belge doit choisir
netflix en place de sortir parce que je
me sens pas bien je suis fatigué épuisé
fait que je vais me tourner vers l'écran
à ce moment là c'est la dépression qui
ferait que gérait plus voir les écrans
mais ça peut aussi avec le contraire au
sens où et je regarde tous les écrans
pis je vois que les gens sont
performants puis moi je me sens pas
assez donc j'ai développé des symptômes
dépressifs vous voyez commence à parler
dans les deux sens non mais il y aura
lieu donc seuil ya un lien ce qu'on dit
ensuite aux jeunes c'est que ces liens
la honte les l'utilisation des médias
sociaux pis les symptômes dépressifs
comment comment ça se fait comment ont
ils commis un lien mais un principal
coupable qu'on disait c'est le sommeil
chez les ados parce que leur grand temps
d'écran veut dire souvent avant de te
coucher souvent moins d'heures de
sommeil puis quand tu dors mal tu es
fatigué et épuisé table etc
ça a un impact beaucoup sur ton humeur
un long chassé si la qualité ton sommeil
est pas bon parce que tu vas pas les
notifications qui travaillent à 2h30 du
matin à cause d'un message le tube
garder l'ossature de la tête l'homme
satan dormir etc en confiance ensuite il
ya d'autres choses comme les autres
facteurs qui vont lier l'utilisation des
médias sociaux symptômes dépressifs et
ça a été ça peut être l'exercice
physique la même manière que pour le
sommet à dire que si je passe beaucoup
de temps pour les écrans sas peur que ça
remplace des activités que cette fois
que je passe beaucoup de temps
menton playstation que tu t'entraînes
cool à ce moment là se dit que ça
s'adresse pas à tous genres est comme
tout le reste on autant d'écrans mais si
tu sens que j'étais en train de moins ou
décident de balata pratiques et de
soccer parce que tu veux jouer à ton jeu
vidéo leye des questions à se poser pour
ton humain ensuite il ya tout qu'est ce
qui est évidemment un an l'insee par
intimidation
si tu fais ça m'intimide à l'école tu
arrives en maison ça continue c'est
évident que ça aura un impact sur ton
humeur
et finalement il estime personne et puis
l'image corporelle qui m'ont lié les
médias sociaux aux symptômes dépressifs
donc ce sont toutes des choses à
regarder et jeux peuvent avoir un impact
sur notre humeur
personnellement puis qui sont démontrés
scientifiquement comme étant des
facteurs qui lie les deux quelqu'un qui
nous écouterait puis qui se reconnaître
et mettons dans comme étant une personne
qui vit de l'anxiété
cet incident est le premier des réseaux
sociaux ou qui seraient victimes de ce
parti nation c'est quoi est-ce que ce
que vous offrez des pistes de solution
des trucs mais tombe pour justement
essayer de diminuer les effets négatifs
des réseaux sociaux mais ça dépend
sisters c'est un truc qui pathologique
le si la personne a fait des liens real
de l'anxiété sociale avec anxiété mais
c'est tant mieux sinon on a rien dans ce
sens où les consultations psychologiques
s'adresse la solution de mes points
d'accord pour sélectionner de la santé
c'est encore possible la personne et
l'accès difficile au début j'ai bien la
meilleure solution c'est la thérapie
parce que j'ai la chance de pouvoir
avoir accès à ça on en est on
on l'a pas mal tous mais c'est pas comme
ça pour pour tout le monde c'est un fait
ça c'est pour les personnes qui ont des
problèmes sérieux parce que des
individus lorsqu'on les études nous
montrent aussi c'est que les personnes
qui sont des jeux est excusé moins à
risque vont avoir plus tendance à avoir
des problèmes psychotiques les
phénomènes sont justes exacerbée par les
médias sociaux la cij fait de l'anxiété
ça risque d'être exacerbées par les
médias sociaux mais si c'est une
personne comme moi j'ai pas d'enquêté et
mes relations sociales ça me stresse pas
comme sur les médias sociaux je ne
ressens pas de stress par rapport à ce
que je projette nécessairement jack icm
et de ces factions on a des problèmes
pour se questionner et de quelle manière
à ce que ça se reflète sur les médias
sociaux
après pour des personnes qui on peut
notamment de troubles mais qu'ils
sentent qu'ils ont une sensibilité qui
écoute le podcast sont qu'un moyen qui
fait que j'ai besoin de prendre
conscience de ce ça commence par une
prise de conscience que c'est vraiment
un long de regarder son temps d'écran de
couper les notifications d'analysé passé
à travers toutes ces applications pour
enlever les notifications de celles qui
sont pas nécessaires ces salariés zoomer
ça allait tellement pas au final puis
quand on change
oui ça change tout petit topo il
à 36 ans j'ai enlevé mes notification le
lendemain je voudrais seulement
instagram que mes messages
autant de fois mais aujourd'hui
maintenant dix mois plus tard je leur ai
marre que les changements faits que
c'est normal qu'ils aient que ça prenne
du temps là finalement oui ben si c'est
un facteur qui comme une existence aux
réseaux sociaux le temps si on a des
publications qui sont affichées les
lions changer l'ordre chronologique le
des fois tu as des publications qui sont
affichés tu fais comme un mets me semble
qu'il m'avait dit où elle m'avait dit
qu'il ou elle était la pile tu fais
avant sinon qu'il a été publié deux
jours mais tout ce que je vois une
publication d'hier de george comme on
est
ça existe plus le temps passe et une des
manières d'une rente confortable de nous
laisser là encore plus longtemps c'est
comme le design d'addiction le un peu
comme les casinos
certains restaurants ils s'organisent
pour castrés reçoit depuis longtemps
puis te rendent tellement confort tant
que tu oublies ce que tu fais le tu
restes là parce qu'on sait que quand tu
restes le ça rapporte de l'argent existe
un c'est ça la fin c'est qu'on ne put où
on a de moins en moins
l'idée que le temps est très favorable
au développement de choses saines c'est
un changement de comportement je prends
la vague de dénonciations le retour
hâtif des personnes qui ont été corrects
pour moi c'est vraiment surprenant
est-ce que c'est chacun non parce que je
comprends le principe je comprends qu
est-ce qui a peu habité une personne qui
voudrait faire ça sans vouloir me mettre
à leur place ou d'assumer des affaires
mais ça prend du temps un fort intérêt
moussa faye 12 j'ai fait de la thérapie
12 ans avant d'arrêter d'avoir des
crises de panique ces 12 c'est leur
équipe
c'est un petit peu moins de la moitié de
ma vie ici puis a fallu que je pense
avoir d'aidé shit man qui était vraiment
vraiment pas le fun fait comme j'ai
tantôt on changera pas le monde demain
matin et mais au moins faut commencer
faut faire un pas très épicée c'est ce
qu'on compte qu'on est cette femme et ça
ça prend du temps fait qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait à dire aux gens on est pas on
sait pas décevant en fait c'est juste
réaliste nous arriver pour moi jamais
décevant la réalité c'est la réalité est
pas bonne est pas mauvaise mais c'est
eux qui décident ce que tu fais avec kim
au juridique mon niveau de bonheur était
intrinsèquement liée à ma capacité de
m'adresser à la réalité c'est quoi qui
est vrai par exemple j'ai un crush
ferment et peut intéresser c'est quoi
qui lèverait pas intéressé et pourrait
de nouveau faire du deal avec man parce
que tu peux pas contrôler les autres
pour rien changé del avec
et après ça ben c'est quoi le skate
c'est quoi tes habileté par rapport à ça
j'ai réalisé que j'ai pas d'habileté
mais au lieu de retourner voir cette
personne ne parle à un ami parlez en aux
personnes les connections dans la vraie
vie les mêmes les livres des deux coachs
de vie où elle averti oui c'est drôle ce
qui génère break up
il ya quelques temps qui a été
extrêmement douloureux puis c'est drôle
j'ai trouvé 1 1 un credo love marbre
rose qui faisait un guide pour guérir
d'un break up j'ai fait quand même un
jeu tellement beau 49 $ us puis ça m'a
tellement aidé chez fait 12 1 térabit je
dis pas que ça va changer quoi que ce
soit mais ça m'a aidé à placer certaines
en france a été un pas de plus je disais
mais je pense que la prise de conscience
de sa propre réalité ta propre
interaction avec ce qui peut créer un
temps c'est l'étape numéro un
puis le problème c'est de savoir qu'on
voit qu'il a prise de conscience on est
obligé de la faire tout seul non plus si
on tend traitons des caisses qui se fait
qu'est ce qui s'est passé médias sociaux
on serait conduit merci il y aurait
moins de règles de bienséance c est ce
parce qu'on tenterait une forge et les
normes sociales là tu t'es fait que si
tu veux prendre conscience de ce qui se
fait ce qui fait peur c'est appel à une
amie pigeant dans un pays lointain
instagram
ça me fait sentir comme ça ça t'arrive
tu dé perdre la notion du temps de te
rends compte que tu es pas là tu sais
quoi tes trucs juste le fait d'en parler
ça oui parce que la pression tu vas voir
les références des gens qui étaient même
période il fait confiance et tour deux
fois autour de toi tu irais fake
ça donne un coup de main aussi mais
c'est tellement de choses puis c'est
pour ça que la mission c'est
d'entretenir une conversation parce que
d'une part ça sera pas tout de suite
puis non pas des plateformes change au
fur et à mesure qu'on pointe leurs
défauts de ce fait que ça prend un
discussions qui vont rouler jusqu'à la
fin des temps en fait résumé la mission
du ciel la prévention avec les jeunes
référé le monde a des ressources quand
comme on n'est pas de l'intervention qui
trouva de fans job de sensibilisation
entre autres par les plateformes
numériques pour entretenir la
conversation on sème des graines d'un
esprit déjà en espérant que ça
fleurissent
très acide est bon et beau maintenant
comprends qu'on se retire un petit peu
delà de l'expérience personnelle puis
qu'on parle du climat des réseaux
sociaux dernièrement pis des réseaux
sociaux non pas comme quelque chose que
chacun en a dans notre poche mais
quelque chose qui existe dans la société
et une point de vue plus sociologique
depuis le début du confinement mais j'ai
senti de plus en plus ainsi vite et de
l'agressivité de l'agressivité par un
envers les autres un espèce de climat
vraiment de plus en plus toxiques qui
bordaient tranquillement puis qui
bouillonnait picon on a vu que le
président hu
après l'accueil du les vagues
dénonciation qu'il est un mouvement
social qui en marque blanche l'as maroc
d'un autre mouvement social qui est
ultra positif dans son ensemble puis la
presse à cette espèce d'effervescence de
mouvements sociaux comme continuer
puis comme devenu un espèce de tu
pouvais pas ouvrir ton c'est l'heure du
moins - mettons avec les gens que je
suivais pas parce que j'avais juste
suivi des comptes de photographies de
landscape c'est parce que ce serait pas
hostile
moi je me retrouverai mon cellulaire ou
instagram sans tomber sur une nouvelle
co sociale sans tomber sur le lionisme
et ancien indignation l'oeil et des
voyageurs des voyageurs qui partait au
mexique qui le co2 aurions pu loi de
véhicules outils puis le mot c'est là
que je me senti qu'on le met où fut
capable de prendre le temps parce que
alex tout si le fait pas de mal logement
aperam et avais dit le mot je m'en vais
des réseaux sociaux
parce qu'en ce moment il ya trop
d'erreurs faut que je réfléchisse avant
de m'exprimer mais c'était possible
d'écouter pendant qu'ils parlent
français fait que pour moi c'était de
moi j'avais eu assez d'information le
jeu
sur les dénonciations les deux
mouvements qui ont été extrêmement
bénéfique pour ma compréhension de
l'impact
j'avais une information fallait que je
me retire puis que je fasse un travail
personnel ensuite dessus
c'est ce climat là est un sous produit
d'une absence de connexion et puis
encore plus loin que le climat qui
s'installe et en est qu'on n'a pas de
connexion fait qu'on n'est pas capable
de se divertir comme on le faisait avant
puis deux in dodge comme on dit en
anglais donc de de vaquer à des
occupations qui nous empêche de faire
des introspections on doit faire des
introspections c'est extrêmement
douloureux c'est super difficile
le climat social des réseaux sociaux
présentement et un est un symptôme de
notre manque de ressources died à
travers à peu près tous les pans de la
société
je m'explique si on m'avait demandé de
parler qu'il se moque des dix matches
parce que je vais aller le parce que
j'ai pas envie de choquer personne parce
que mon désir c'est pas de choquer mon
désir c'est d'écouter d'apprendre de
comprendre qu'il poser des gestes pour
que ça change
puis j'ai réalisé que tu fais jamais
trop de bruit
quant au besoin des aides si tu sors
d'ici peut-être la jambe démarche puis
aux personnes souvent crié jusqu'à temps
qu'on entend depuis qu'on te donne des
soins
wright basket à fort kent gens mais
péter puis tu va saigner ton corps au
complet puis tu vas crever
culturellement j'avais envie de dire que
c'est faux que manu progressons navette
à l'école ensemble répond l'une de ses
plus beaux crevé on rit on est
épouvantable ce jour
j'ai lu j'ai justement sur ce genre
abate moi comme un vieux rhinocéros mâle
les tricératops et patrick gilles est un
livre qui s'appelle imhoff aidé par un
psychologue américain qui s'appelle
green green qui a aussi fait un livre
qui s'appelle halte fixe gros connards
qui m'avait aidé en complément avec
leurs nombreux comme beaucoup de séries
phares au point et beaucoup de serbes
sans vraiment fait du bien dans une
motion au freestyle games met en lumière
le fait que culturellement on ne
s'adresse jamais au trauma émotionnelle
comme on s'adresse aux tourments
physiques
si tu pètes la jambe d'un marche il y en
à blanc ce qui va venir quelqu'un va
plutôt en vrai au mic à têtu correct tu
pourras peut-être pas travailler pendant
deux mois
toutes les ressources dont est à
disponibilité la csst assure en tout cas
comme plein d'affaires pour ce site sort
du si tu apprends que une nouvelle qui
était dévastée mais il n'ya personne qui
va faire comme en kit à tous besoin des
dons va pas amener à l'urgence des
troubles émotionnels outils ça n'existe
pas donc pour les personnes qui
utilisent les réseaux sociaux pour crier
à l'aide
moi moi ça m'a fait énormément parce que
je réalise que ces gens là c'est tout ce
qu'ils ont puis la culture rock pour moi
c'est ce camp on pointe la culture web
du doigt je vais donner le meilleur
exemple c'est à beaucoup de gens des
communautés marginalisées qui sont comme
on veut militer pour lévis noir transe
comme go blanc privilégie convient style
donne moi un au québec
c'est mon premier réflexe mon réflexe
dgo sauf qu'en même temps si une
personne dit j'ai mal à la jambe alors
qu'il y en a deux jambes très correct je
peux pas faire ça parce que la personne
amarrage esti j'aimerais passablement la
jambe c'est juste que j'ai de la
difficulté à m'identifier à cet enjeu le
donc mon premier réflexe est de me faire
voyons c'est dormez dérangeant c'est un
glaçant même question chiffres je sais
pas c'est difficile d'accès difficile
d'avoir une personne souffrir pour autre
chose qu'à un trauma physique qui est un
trouble physique aussi difficile mais
c'est du sida pour cette personne à
souffrir parce que tu sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'il faut que tu fasses tu dis faudrait
que je passe de quoi je veux pas que
cette personne ne sait encore si on ne
sait pas quoi faire
chants de voir ton incapacité à réagir à
ce jeu prend l'exemple de mathieu
bock-côté qui ni sur toutes les plaques
- premièrement quand il dit que la meuse
à s'exprimer puisque y ait payé des
centaines de milliers de dollars par
année pour le faire sur différentes
plateformes jusqu'aux abords et prends
ton gaz égal puis je me dis pourquoi est
ce qu'on demande à mathieu bock côté de
nous parler de racisme systémique
qu'est ce t'en sais où tu déjà été
victime de ce concept le moi je pense
qu'on devrait donner la place aux gens
qui arrêtent pas de crier qui est du
racisme systémique qui en souffrent puis
mettons le que ce pauvre et on peut tu
veux savoir la conversation
est-ce qu'on peut arrêter de me douter
ces gens là avec du monde qui ont des
plateformes énormes qui sont payés
beaucoup d'argent pour le faire
moi je trouve ça fort cher parce que ce
qui arrive après c'est que ces personnes
là vont nous mettons partir des déchets
par des personnes qui sont affectées
vont partir dé trend et rennes vont
devenir populaire ya des gens qui vont
se l'approprier qui vont faire des
articles
le trimaran je te parle du racisme
systémique va devenir entraîne toutes
les médias vont se mêler de tout ça
quand ça va parler de tout les gens vont
intéresser ça va générer des clics sans
générer de l'argent à qui l'argent va
profiter aux mêmes personnes qui ai
l'habitude chaque mois ce qui est ce que
ce que j'ai à dire au mouvement works et
arrêtez jamais de parler parce qu'à un
moment donné quelqu'un à eau qui va
faire le s'il faut je pense je pense que
la solution c'est de faire de quoi à
quel point était privilégié dans la vie
quand tu es là à regarder du monde qui
sauf puis à dire vous devriez souffrir
autrement vous devriez dire autrement
que vous souffrez ça ça me fait ça me
fait halluciner
puis tout ça parce qu'on ne reconnaît
pas la souffrance psychologique d'un
groupe de gens marginalisés
je comprends je te parle de blake lively
en remettons les noms sont comme un
higgs
même si ça fait des années que plus d
esclavage on souffre encore de trauma
générationnel de racisme systémique
d'oppression la police qui nous arrête
en surnombre pilote à des gens qui sont
comme ben voyons donc c'est un doute
c'est tellement gratifiant tantôt je ne
sais pas parce que c'est plus
sophistiqué que c'est moins violent pour
moi un gars qui qui qui donne un coup de
poing à une personne whaou qui disent
les faits elle même c'est tout aussi
violent c'est juste que c'est
sophistiqué s'est fait sous le couvert
de la liberté d'expression pittis au
fait que pour moi la culture hook
c'est juste le rêve
d'une société c'est le réveil des gens
oubliés de la société qui fait comme le
savoir faire puis on leur donner les
outils idéal pour le faire et il s'en
sert pour ce fac après dans une position
privilégiée qu'est ce que tu peux faire
moi je pense que la meilleure attitude à
adopter celle écoute en écoutant tu vas
apprendre des choses qui en apprenant
des choses un maronite votre
conscientiser sur ton pouvoir sur ces
choses montrées matin je peux parler à
l'assemblée nationale est passée
d'écouter les noirs s'il vous plaît j'ai
pas ce pouvoir là mais j'ai le pouvoir
de rassembler peut-être ces personnes
âgées pouvoir de trouver des stratégies
pour les aider à passer de ce va puiser
dans des habilités petit dico match pour
remettre mais habile mais habilité à
profit pour les groupes marginalisés
minorisées et l'autre aux actions mais
tu peux pas poser d'actions toyota qui
n'a pas écouté assimilés compris ça ça
peut prendre des années
puis c'est un peu pour ça tant que je
disais que j'étais en mode écoute en ce
moment parce que je crains c'est
tellement overwhelming moi ça m'affecte
le à côté il ya des soirs il
je comprends toujours sa une et pas au
stick arcade se remplit n'est pas au
genou pour la vidéo puis la tordue
l'impression que tout ce que j'ai
accumulée dans dernières années sur les
réseaux sociaux dédiés des sceaux que
j'ai besoin de brailler parce que c'est
la seule réponse que j'ai agi comme et
stx et overwhelming mais en même temps
je suis tellement fort king chanceux de
me de pouvoir avoir cette opportunité là
deux sites à 6 pi brailler alors qu'ils
étaient du monde qui sont chez eux à
avoir faim à se faire taper dessus à
cause de la couleur de leur peau ou à ce
faire
après c'est à cause de leur identité que
je me dis même si ces jeux seul prix à
payer c'est vraiment pas super mais ça
vient d'un an de réflexion parce qu'au
début ça me gausser même chez croyons si
ce principe est qu'elle soit barack
obama y est président à billets noirs
sauf que ça va plus loin seul puis c'est
fou même parce que plus tu creuses petit
réalises que tu sais rien c'est comme je
sais plus quel philosophe avait du
sommet il dit la plus grande joie c'est
de savoir que tu sais rien finalement
parce que ça aurait jamais te plier
tellement de nuances que tellement de
choses pour ça qu'on a grandi à des
trucs très pointu aujourd'hui c'est plus
genre les noirs ont pas de joie parce
qu'ils sont annoncés comme des petits
des micros on parle des micros agression
récemment jeté comme ben voyons donc ça
va trop loin le j'ai commencé à lire sur
une progression de jeu comme ça fait
totalement de sens mon meilleur exemple
que j'ai dans mon cas moi c'est les
travailleurs de travail
les travailleurs du sexe au début
j'étais comme est vraiment con qu'on
devrait encourager les travailleurs du
sexe ça n'a pas de bon sens à vendre son
corps montrer cette attente faire de
l'argent puis je suis partie d'un groupe
qui pensaient sûr il ya un embargo qui
se dit pourquoi ne pas de syndicat
provincial public pour venir en aide à
ces personnes là ce qu'on prend c'est
impératif que ces personnes là soient en
santé puis en sécurité parce que il ya
rétro pas en avant demain matin parce
que toi ça te choque quelques toi ta
cousine island livre le ch'ti ce qu'on
va faire je pense que c'est important
d'écouter
je pense que c'est important d'apprendre
je pense que c'est important de résister
le plus possible à l'ego qui dit à ce
moustique à l'assaut de manger tout de
la mare de mal au chalet montfa du sud
où ça va passer malheureusement on vit
tous les problèmes auxquels on s'est
jamais adressé dans toutes les
générations d'avant la marque avec la
royauté le racisme à travers la royauté
les toutes les connexions avec des gens
qui sont absolument pas fréquentable
depuis les médias sociaux nous ont
permis d'avoir accès à tout ce féculent
c'est comme si une piscine dans le
complot c'est le printemps
celui-ci que des feuilles dans le fond
puis quelqu'un qui a pris une perche
puis qui recommencent à ce grade absent
depuis tout est revenu à la surface
comme omar sy god i et lots les feuilles
c'est juste que le sont à surface qu'il
faut que tu aies j'aurais fait après
ceux de paul contrôle sur ce que les
gens vont dire et peut-être pas le
contrôle sur comment les gens vont dire
qu'ils souffrent mettant le contrôle sur
comment il va aborder la question qu'est
ce que tu vas poser comme action pour
essayer d'aider ces gens le site est en
position de le faire n'était pas en
position de le faire tout à fait rage et
où il ya personne qui doit te bovy into
acting parce que de toute façon ça va
être performatif ce que tu vas faire
puis ça va être un coup d'épée dans
l'eau fait pour moi c'est d'écouter la
culture work
mais en janvier packard y ait des
chroniqueurs comme richard martineau
sophie durocher mathieu bock-côté qui
disent comme or c'est bien là ce temps
les jeunes le sont tout le temps blessé
violence comme elle crise fait 200 à 300
milles par amnesty pour être un journal
de montréal tu peux tu juste laisser la
place à ceux qui disent qu'il souffre
juste le juste de t'expliquer prend cinq
minutes qui écoutent mais c'est plus
haut c'est comme c'est comme le mal
contre le bien ccc les privilégiés
contre les gens qui ont qui n'ont pas de
voix puis je trouve ça vraiment triste
parce que je me dis calmement
qu'est-ce que je peux faire mon come
into you see me demande quand même
c'est bien mon tête bâtiments dans les
salles mais tellement encore les
objectifs maintenant à faire sur
lesquels on peut rebondir
je me questionne juste dans la dans
l'image que tu peins entre la personne
en privilège qui doit écouter la
personne
les personnes de retard je suis 100%
d'accord que tu écoutes les personnes
qui vivent la pression se sait sur pete
tu peux dont nous tous une introspection
à former selon ses capacités je
comprends absolument
par contre j'ai l'impression qu'en dix
ans eux ont favorisé encore on va encore
à l'envers de les changes
moi c'est moi si c'est ça que je trouve
qui est le plus important c'est parce
que mettons tu parles de mathieu bock
côté mathieu bock-côté on demande de
s'exprimer sur beaucoup trop d'accord
sur beaucoup trop d'affaires qui quitte
pas son expertise mais je suis persuadé
qu'il discuterait avec n'est pas oubliée
qui amène une démo je crois pas qu'il ya
des sujets qui sont bloqués dans le
béton qui ne doivent pas être discuté de
sony non mais attention parce que c'est
comme tout le monde
les personnes qui vont critiquer bon on
sait quoi qu'on fait référence au monde
sauf ils sont peu compte le des bonnes
en plus chaque côté il ya des personnes
qui savent bien s'exprimer des personnes
qui sont pas là pour être débattue piqué
ce qu'alexandre tata grandes envolées
lyriques
en fait c'est ce que je vois c'est le
travail qui est fait au niveau de
l'intelligence émotionnelle c'est à dire
que je reçois sur le bien dit tantôt
d'arriver sur ton instagram pitt avait
perdu le contrôle du contenu parce que
dès que tu ouvres instagram tu avais
quelque chose sur les dénonciations
publiques c'est à dire que toi
normalement dans l'espace public et on
promet donc comme ben lente et peu sauf
si une émission spéciale sur le racisme
et on invite les quatre comédiens noirs
de l'autre en parler mais qui sera pas
confronté à ce tandis que lot était
obligé de le voir le des jeux tu es
obligé 30 confiance de ton privilège
pirate met dans une position
inconfortable puis je dise tu parce que
je parle au dessus là mais moins pareil
donc ça nous oblige est dans une posture
inconfortable ça nous oblige nous
remettent en question s'est passé
vraiment je suis d'accord avec thierry
médias sociaux et des fois on dit en
fait dedans on pourrait couper tous les
médias sociaux c'est vraiment privilégié
parce que ça serait coupé une manière d
2 pour plein jeu sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya juste les chroniqueurs de tve qui
semble bien
on choisit donc au moins il ya une
chance pour les gens de se représenter
mais après en vain le positif de ce
secteur plein de voix commune qui
s'élève ensemble pour amener un message
le côté négatif de ça c'est que c'est
plein de voix qui viennent de plaine
environnement différent qui s'expriment
pas de la même manière et des personnes
qui font parler beaucoup d'émotion
d'autres personnes - lille on essaie de
toutes les mains toutes les mettre dans
le même bateau puis ça fonctionne pas
comme ça il y avait une formule qu'on
entendait souvent c'était dans ces
mouvements là c'était éducateurs et
celle ci est dit que tu essaies of you
you il ya des connaissances cgt le
racisme le sexisme tout c'est moi isme
souvent viennent d'une ignorance
si j'ai peur de mon prochain si j'aime
pas mon voisin est noir il ya une
question d'ignorance là dedans si je dis
maintenant ya là je voyais héros dont
six aux états unis l'avaient jamais
d'esclavagé si il y en a eu c'est un
fait
il ya des choses sur lesquelles on doit
cdu qui on doit apprendre pour connaître
factuellement même et c2c de prendre
pour acquis que tout le monde a les
ressources pour s'inscrire
oui c'est pour tout le monde y allait
même le débat on parle comme si on part
en une femme qui est un homme qui parle
de sexisme au commun des bottes d'égal à
égal par dont six lancements par les
violences faites aux femmes en ce moment
- ce moment j'ai plein de flashbacks t
non mais je pense que je dis c'est pas
pour qu'on prenne en pitié mais juste
pour qu'on respecte et que parfois ce
qu'on dit de pas faire du tort au racing
c'est de dire qu'en ce moment on
dialogue avec des personnes
marginalisées qui ont vécu des
injustices puis qui ont droit d'avoir
une frustration puis mon postulat de ces
ententes personnes privilégiées
je vais essayer d'être la vigueur
personnes qui peuvent être fragiles
il me faut reprocher des choses
jusque-là personne mais le cri de
subtiles j'ai essayé de prendre sur moi
puis d'écouter malgré tout après je sais
que c'est pas donné à tout le monde
gentiment en pis pour les chats pour
qu'ils aient lieu des changes il faut
qu'à la base il ya une ouverture puis je
pense que quand une personne opprimés et
une personnes privilégiées comme
personnes privilégiées
la personne doit fabre doit être de
biger personne faire preuve de
d'ouverture parce qu'elle est quelqu'un
qui souffre en ce moment qu'ils
comprennent ce qui se pète la jambe
devant toi t'as faim tu va vouloir
l'aider mexicain vient du bain - cause
de la couleur de ma peau je sens que
j'ai apprécié de se faire aux riches à
commencer un petit add ons petit envoyé
à l'urgence ou guy marty il faut qu'ils
aient un système mis en place pour sap
80 on se demande est ce qu'il faut aller
voir ci dessus les réseaux sociaux sites
du gouvernement si tu les individus mais
quand je disais c'est prendre pour
acquis que tout le monde peut s'éduquer
de la même manière je comprends pas
pourquoi dans les écoles on n'a pas
cette histoire mon histoire du canada et
du québec on m'a appris l'instant un peu
de la bullshit
non ceci que le jeudi envoyant don au
stick est issu à 31 ans qui avait eu de
l'esclave de l' esclavage au canada
jeudi
c'est important parce que si on apprend
ce bien là maintenant je peux mieux
comprendre où je suis plus habilitée à
recevoir la plainte d'un ami ou une ami
noir orpi de comprendre son son sa
réalité que si on change tombe des nues
je fais comme voyons tu veux juste de
l'attention et puis je trouve que de
dire que les gens de maison les gens qui
émettent le ses problèmes avec l'esat
c'est vraiment un problème puis ça
empêche le dire la preuve c'est comme
quand tu pointes les gens sur l'aide
sociale
le faible pourcentage de gens sur l'aide
sociale qui font de la fraude au lieu de
te reverrai vers l'immense majorité de
gens riches qui profitent de la fraude
fiscale bellemène jeudi c'est vraiment
un problème parce que il y en a très peu
dans dans pige aux lots il ya de l'homme
il ya de l'hommerie halle
mais il ya très peu de gens dans ces
situations là qui font se prendre la
tension à nous ça peut paraître comme
cette récurrence et populeux sauf qu'il
sera rejeté
ce que je veux encourager dans le fond
c'est l'écouté d'ouverture je dirais que
c'est vraiment hoffman s'arrêter là all
blacks les marais les dénonciations tous
les mouvements sociaux qui ont suivi
jeter comme moins qu'annoncé
je trouve ça dur j'ai trouvé ça dur de
lire les témoignages pas d'entendre les
gens sprint j'ai trouvé ça dur de voir
qu est ce qui est arrivé aux gens jetés
qu'on lui demande c'est si tu lisais
moyenne il faut tarir dans un débat qui
s'est pas tout le monde que les mangues
si tu le dis monter peut-être pas et
l'éducation qui les outils pour
comprendre la pression de la personne en
face de toi qui est aussi quelqu'un on
parlait de polarisation sur les médias
sociaux tantôt insultes mettons que moi
je fais partie de groupes féministes etc
qui développe vote
blair qui développe des expressions que
le mot wac idapt 2019 mais qu'il a
depuis vraiment longtemps qu'ils vont
dire des mots comme féminisme
intersectionnelle etc
[ __ ] autres groupes eux ça va être
complètement contraire pilote à une
personne que chacun son vocabulaire qui
va arriver dans la même boîte de
commentaires
donc c'est sûr qu'elle ait quelqu'un
pour être bon le sort les grands mots ou
être sur le grand et perfectionner en un
an je comprends pas qu est ce que tu dis
mais la personne a l'impression d'être
clair parce que dans sa communauté
c'est les mots qu'il utilise ta que des
fois c'est diversion qui ont même pas
serment mais doit encore vraiment la
natation
quand tu es encore justement lutter
l'ouverture c'est à dire ça mais telle
ouverture de aussi sphère des deux côtés
puissent quelqu'un utilise pas le bon
terme au bon moment où nous exprime pas
son support à une cause de la bonne
façon mais que les intentions sont
bonnes je pense qu'il faut quand même je
pense que c'est contreproductif de mme
et ont traîné dans la boue publiquement
quelqu'un qui veut juste bien femme
qu'il fait maladroitement j'ai besoin
qu'ils aient besoin d'éducation qu'ils
aient besoin de faire exprimer certaines
notions plus que ces personnes 2 à 10 ou
screenshots mais ce publiquement on va
l'attaquer tait soit on peut pas
fonctionner comme ça dans par un débat
sain pour moi ça s'écoute et que ces
écoutes ça ça arrive trop souvent pour
moi ça c'est le point principal parce
que ce qu'on dit depuis tantôt on est
tous le monde à lyon du racisme et isola
mauvais tout le monde d'accord sur tout
le monde d'accord sur le fait que je pas
à moi de parler de mon expérience de
racisme en moi de parler de racisme j'ai
rien à voir là dedans j'ai jamais vécue
je suis le gars le plus privilégié
l'histoire de l'humanité et puis tout
seul on s'entend tout le monde sait mais
après sur moi je trouve que wes que
c'est quand qu'on entend à temps une
professeur d'université qui fait un
cours de féminisme puis qui dit femmes
et hommes puis qu'à chaque fois que des
femmes à se fait traiter de transport au
point wasquehal arrêtent d'enseigner
parce qu'ils étaient capables dans un
court de tennis soit pour moi c'est une
dérape
ma mère a menacé sarsiat la discussion
je messieurs s'annonce
ses toiles sont pas là au dialogue c'est
pas la règle tu as raison que ces deux
cépages enseigne à l'université au
département communication université de
montréal a fait tout tout non mais qui
ça revient exactement son métro
d'attention sur la tête chantal puig
illustre quand même le fait qu' on veut
pas que sa ré arrive parce qu'on veut
garder un dialogue ouvert et puis on
veut garder entre idéalement et les
étudiants tous les étudiants conquis qui
pose ses gestes lors qu'ils soulèvent
des questions puis la charge la chargés
de cours il y aura une discussion puis
l'université encadrerait cette
discussion l'heure pour qu'elle se fasse
dans le respect parce que bon il peut
tout le temps avoir des débordements
quand et comme on le dit la quantité d à
pression et c'est que tu le vis comme
une micro agression c'est mieux que ce
soit quand encadrés par l'université
l'institution après moi j'ai un problème
avec ce qu'on veut et pointer du doigt
les étudiants et les étudiantes et d'un
courtès comme si on avait un double
discours des fois on et comment elle et
je ne sont pas assez politisé on sort
des statistiques sur le nombre de jeunes
qui vont et aux ions de combien de
personnes votent longtemps ils sont les
causes des séries américaines et il
s'intéresse pas politique en étant sont
plus souverainiste les jeunes voyons
dont ils s'intéressent pas politiquement
pique quand il s'y met à dire des
déclarations
c'est sûr que l'intimidation sait jamais
si jamais là si jamais la solution de
chat vivant mais ça en même temps et en
20 ans c'est quand ils ont 21 ans il
appréhende t on peut tu ne pas moins en
tant que chargé co sarry dans mon cours
je le prends sur moi je pense j'estime
pas que la personne de 20 ans foca
qu'elles agissent comme si elle savait
comment débattre qu'elle avait été 1000
dons pendant 40 ans avec le ce que je
trouve des programmes dans ce débat le
sait que wim intensément le fil à
l'intimidation mais c'est de recevoir la
critique d'une populace de mouvements
des gens qui se mobilisent qu'ils disent
de se donner à l'université dire comment
est ce que tu me protège en tant que
chargé de cours
comment est-ce qu'on a encore des
discussions là dedans moi je pointerais
beaucoup plus t'es sur qui sont à
l'université que les jeunes étudiants
qui finalement sont juste allumer le
si on pense que ça vient me chercher je
n'ai encore l'annulation par l'inde
étudiant de 19 ans qui vivaient chez
leurs parents c'est des gens qui ont des
idées puis un espoir dans vip qui ont un
stade g qui fait là j'ai décidé de
fermer quand on a des centaines qui
tombe dans tes messages privés pourtant
sa responsabilité a quitté dont klaus et
cédric esson le déplore c'est une
mauvaise manière des dialogues geek qui
- après je me tourne vers ce qu'on peut
faire inverse conduite 80 au t2 de
critiquer la façon dont j'ai reçu comme
traducteur faire ça j'ai l'impression
que j'ai l'impression que ça revient à
la communication puis au dialogue tout
le temps pitié tout le temps moyen étant
donné que les plateformes sur lesquelles
ça se passe sont pas fait pour ça
c'est seul volume ça devient suspense et
seul progresse clairement ce qui arrive
là tu sais comme une publication c'est
frv sens on pense à d'autres choses mais
un enjeu social la mécanique pour le
transformer est absolument pas du tout
réplique à bhl sur les médias sociaux
exact fait pour ce qui est important de
prendre un stade bac puis d'avoir des
qualités au niveau de l'intelligence
émotionnelle puis de développer son
psyché puis d'écouter puis d'être en
fait c'est de l'humilité men c'est juste
c'est juste un gros exercice d'humilité
de cépie on le fait tous du pur vrai je
connais personne qui fait pas du mieux
qu'ils peuvent me connais pas ces codes
sources et là je pense que le problème
et puis j'ai déjà eu des conversations
sans rentrer trop dans les détails des
conversations parce que j'avais
l'impression que avant de parler d'un
sujet fallait leur fasse le chemin
l'entièreté de mon raisonnement jusqu'au
moment où est-ce que j'étais avec
mettons ces mots je pense que c'est
juste normal parce que à chaque fois à
chaque fois qu'une chaîne
maintenant je veux donner l'exemple mais
ton de dire moi clairement je suis
contre les agressions sexuelles qui est
sûr je pense que c'est claude cliquet
mettons dans la vague de dénonciations
qu'un qu'une liste anonymes qui est
sorti qui étaient 2000 noms avec deux
commentaires déplacés à viola bout de
couteau moi j'ai quand même fait dans
une discussion à quelqu'un qui a des
projets mois les faits
moi je pense pas que ce soit la façon de
le faire
puis en disant cela je pensais pas que
j'allais avoir besoin de recommencer
tout le chemin de dire eh ben haddou et
le jeudi seuls sur la sur la liste à
l'énigme et de wisches pas pour les
agressions que je défends pas les
agresseurs sur cette liste lo pti puis
j'ai l'impression que si on partait avec
la prémisse que les gens qui s'expriment
pillent des gens racistes y ait des gens
sexistes puis la société raciste la
société sexiste jeu semble en annexe
mais si on pense que la prémisse que les
gens qui s'expriment fondent leurs
possibles sont refoulés fond de bonne
foi si on part avec la promesse que
possiblement que mathieu bock-côté est
pas raciste mais que le point qui amène
sur la société puis les politiques
d'immigration part d'un point vue le
sociologue mais pas fondamentalement
raciste
j'ai l'impression qu'on pourrait plus se
parler si on partait avec la prémisse
que les gens sont déjà avancés dans leur
raisonnement la différence je pense que
on parle peu de gens qui allaient
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on achète
ou d'un truc c'est que tout quand tu dis
ça à chaud c'est difficile d'avoir à
tout réexpliquer à redire challengeant
pour toi d'avoir a réaffirmé que les
convocations
vraiment rendue pour les victimes c'est
pas nous savons ce que je tombais que ça
te demande un effort à faire ce mandat
libéral a aimé ton de tout le temps dit
notre posture qui d'abord besoin de
partir petit de rappeler deux on est
contre les agressions sexuelles etc
c'est comme s'il y avait une possibilité
qu'on soit pas aussi un petit peu oui ça
nous demande cet effort mais on fait cet
effort là parce que les personnes sont
blessées je pense que oui croire que les
gens sont bons mais aussi continuer de
déployer cette forme là de dire tchèque
voici ce que je comprends contre les
agressions sexuelles etc
je trouve sexy jaune tout rappeler ce
juste pour avoir une conversation mais
je veux le faire parce que je trouve ça
important de débattre sais tu que je
comprends tu te retrouves seul os et
l'eau mais maintenant faut toujours
aller au rythme du plu l'instant on est
toujours à la merci des personnes qui
sont les moins fortes et les plus lentes
puis-je du procès de manière péjorative
je dis ça parce que si tu ce qui marque
le plus loin sur ben oui parce que je
voudrais c'est seul but de la société
c'est d'élever les gens qui sont en bas
c'est c'est de rattraper les gens qui
sont qui sont en europe sont trop loin
c'est de rassembler tout le monde pour
qu'on ait des opportunités égales c'est
je vous donne un exemple vraiment
niaiseuse je parle encore d'autres euros
par jour parce que je trouve qu'il ya
des enfants qui sont arrivés qui m'ont
tellement ouvert l'esprit sur des trucs
un moment donné on avait mis un livre en
vente
créée il ya eu des délais dans
l'impression du livre les listes sont
arrivés trois jours plus tard le temps
une personne qui fait ce pari pour ce
beau livre 1
c'est à cause que trois jours de retard
deuxième personne j'ai pour ce mot rive
ouest parce qu'il ya eu trois jours de
retard à la 50e personne n'avait envie d
être tabarnak
on a eu des démêlés c'était à l'eau
aucune idée qui a 200 personnes qui ont
écrit avant petit peu pas poignée de
radiance je te lis dix semaines annonce
le mot juste une personne différente le
gauche quelqu'un qui s'est fait pour moi
c'est même si tu as far se met encore
une fois les réseaux sociaux appellent à
faire ça parce qu'il ya plusieurs
personnes qui de woippy
il ya aussi un une grande destitution de
la confiance en nos institutions nos
sens où c'est l'homme blanc privilégiées
on sait ce que ça donnait une loi
travail on a toute l'histoire pour nous
rappeler à quel point ça a été les
personnes les plus dommage
abl et donc c'est normal peut-être pour
une victime ne pas prendre pour acquis
que dans ton système de valeurs tous
souhaitent intégrer
puis par respect pour cette personne là
et pour son expérience des fois faut
revenir en arrière mais en même temps tu
es pas obligé d'être engagés dans ces
conversations le lien qui t'oblige à
publiquement prendre parole mais si tu
le fais il faut que tu saches que il va
y avoir un travail à faire pour défaire
un peu l'image que tu pourrais avoir
pour un sou de se partir sur une base
neutre est constituée tapant séoul a
livré à la personne qui en auraient
besoin
fake oui c'est chiant mais je pense que
c'est un passage obligé
puis ça vient avec l'art est il le fait
que tu puisse l'exprimer publiquement à
plusieurs personnes c'est un privilège
c'est comme une des unes des
responsabilités qui vient avec sa fête
oui c'est chiant mais c'est chiant aussi
aller s'entraîner mais comme tu as des
résultats après ensemble c'est un peu je
pense qu'en première fois c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant sur les
médias sociaux comme je résume gilles et
aucun article kg lucas était partagé par
nelly brillant qu'on a reçus au bac cap
piqué elle est comme spécialiste des
médias sociaux en garde tout comme les
nouvelles affaires des plates formes et
c est une bonne personne à suivre ça
nous intéresse et qui a partagé un
article qui parlait de la gratification
qui disait je prenais le mot comme si un
foot pour une par une pile aux gens de
gratification immédiate relié à l'image
qui il parlait justement de cette
culture de l'indignation
puis comment est-ce que des fois être
indigné c'était une gratification
immédiate
beaulieu des transports à quelque chose
de plus longues et plus ardue donc
disons que genre monsieur patate qui ont
eu peu de gens mais si tu commences gens
et c'est vraiment n'importe quoi ou
voire aux bravos de l'impression de
transport à un débat alors qu'en réalité
pas du tout m quand même une
gratification de dieu parce que bon de
fait l'action dit quand même une
symbolique a commenté et tu vas
peut-être recueillir des like attaquer
quelqu'un qui va venir en parler de
l'impression pas partie d'un des beaux
jeux de société et sur l'identité de
genre alors qu'au fond j'entre rien
faire est une application immédiate
pilotes comme vous au chili oui mais je
pense pas qu'ils étaient on voit pas le
mot culture du temps tout mais je pense
pas qu'il y aura un petit je pense pas
qu'un problème le jeu park un problème
sur les réseaux sociaux
justement de deux exactement ce peu
importe l'enjeu je voulais dire mon
opinion de manière super vraiment c'est
pas tranché sur le mur sur le roi là
dany turcotte parce que j'ai pas aimé ça
jack pour l'insulter puisque ça peut
venir pour l'insulter ou pour y faire
prendre conscience du fait qu'il ya une
énorme privilège
qu'est-ce qui viennent de dire ça parce
pop idol et une majorité de gens c'est
comme l'humoriste les deux existent mais
si on fait de la même façon si c'est si
j'exprime un désaccord d'une manière en
exposant un point qui a découvert puis
en ouvrant une discussion bien des boss
est une chose puis jeudi
votre plan de montabard n'en sait
absolument pas la même chose qui n a
rien que je constat légitime peut-être
que je fais de ton de police mais pour
moi l'aude n'est pas légitime c'est même
si la cause est bonne si on s'entend
tous que les causes sont bonnes la cyber
intimidation pour moi si jamais un
recours ça l'a aidé à élever non c'est
sûr c'est sûr que ça ait de pommes en
même temps qu'il est un travail
excellent à faire sur les médias sociaux
mais tout le travail d'empathie donc
entre pôles énergie la personne qu'on
n'a pas la personne en présence c'est
vraiment offert comme je dis c'est pas
des plateformes pour écouter on sait que
le fait pour écouter de par la nature de
ces choses là c'est pas fait pour
écouter c'est pas fait pour devenir
empathique ce sont les mouvements aussi
le sien baup et distraire son conseil
pour te détendre pour te distraire pour
le tarif vis-à-vis avec section ski de
choc je pensais que je suivais juste des
pages
j'arrive vis-à-vis c'est des politiques
comme qu'est ce qui se passe puis
peut-être que tu vas prendre ta personne
n'a empêché vous mettons tu vois c'est
que dany turcotte la personne appelée
chez vous pour en discuter
donc pas de lien c'est mon bâton
j'appelle ma mère puis on pendait dany
turcotte billets personnes qui veulent
donc je le fais pas sur les médias
sociaux mais quelqu'un qui est seul il
va peut-être commenté j'ai un petit
l'effet de commenter puis comme quand on
parlait de cette gratification immédiate
le sur laquelle j'insiste c'est beaucoup
plus facile que prendre un temps de côté
pour teddy strates soit on s'est eu
plein mais parce que je suis beau riche
et et j'avais tant pratiques envers lui
je vais réfléchir à l'espace culturel
québécois c'est quoi la place de tout le
monde en parle depuis les dix dernières
années pourquoi de ce serment de
l'effort moi mais c'est pas encourager
culturellement pisser pape ayant fait
quand tu es dans un système en plus qui
est basée sur des relations économiques
de personne à personne et obi seul c'est
pas du tout de la place pour pour le
faire heureusement qu'on a des podcasts
comme ça d'ailleurs je dois faire un
move dans la vraie vie j'ai des enfants
mais je trouve ça fort intéressant puis
je veux juste nommé le fait que je sais
que des gens qui vont voir ça y est
apparemment des gens qui vont vous
écrire écrire manu m'écrire moi je suis
ouvert à toute discussion
pis puis je tends processus le puits on
est on l'est tous qui je sais pas de
dédouaner quoi que ce soit mais je pense
jusqu'à la fin du sud qui est important
de reconnaître c'est le pouvoir compter
individuellement sur notre propre
utilisation des médias sociaux mais
aussi sur un peu là le bien-être des
gens sont et une communauté apple choix
de vivre les uns avec les autres ont
levé avec la pandémie ça fait 1-1 ap il
ya des flashes à terre il ya des images
qui a porté d'une certaine façon
puis encore des gens qui le portent pas
de la bonne manière ça prend du temps
faire des changements qui sont qui sont
qui sont adéquats puis qui sont basés
sur la pérennité et sont durables et
qu'ils sont durs avec cinq thèmes en
fait tu peux pas bobby quelqu'un ou tout
acte thing c'est une phrase que j'étais
à moitié français moitié en anglais
parce que je trouve que la france est
bien fait
en fait c'est juste d'être humble plus
possible je pense je pense pas été une
sommité à ce niveau le jeu fait des
efforts mais si je peux parler des
erreurs que j'ai faites ça peut aider du
monde tant mieux sinon le ciel pour un
ca
merci beaucoup honnêtement merci pour
l'opportunité puis jsk prévention non
c'était pas le premier que nous propose
là et fantastique s'il ya une conclusion
mais j'avais de tricher la mienne a
motivé ce que tu as dit si j'ai
l'impression dans un diction ses impôts
positionner comme pour dire les go on
s'exprime que vous vous êtes com - mais
des fois ça dépend ce liban puis je
trouve que je trouve que c'est à l'image
du débat qu'il faut avoir présentement
où est-ce qu'on trace la ligne
qu'est-ce qu'on accepte qu est-ce qui
est la cyberintimidation qu'est ce qui
légitime qu'est ce qu'ils l'époque puis
moins jeune génération le ci devant ses
pensées pour en parler
oui faut en parler le char grandi de
cette conversation au club j'ai
l'impression que les fonds non réclamés
grande fille jouait ce contrat souligne
certes important mais aussi vous est-ce
qu'on trace la ligne sur une opinion qui
divergeraient mettons deux méthodes du
courant passe et principale ou est
contrastée en ligne entre une opinion
avec les cachent dans les accords avec
un jeu peut converser débattent et c'est
un discours inutiles
oui faut si ces complications le serrant
ça c'est très compliqué le pire nous dit
on a des belles choses qui s'en viennent
avec la fondation sur justement
exactement cet enjeu on a parlé avec
catherine fourni qui est dépendante qui
est député mais les députés indépendants
à l'assemblée nationale pour marie
victorin puis on a parlé de ça comment
on montera s'alignent déjà des choses
qui sont mis en place et par les
plateformes et par les gouvernements et
par les individus fait qu on adresse
tous ces enjeux le avec le plus
d'humilité possible sans diaboliser
sans pointer personne du doigt sans
jugement je pense que ça on veut créer
un livre à un environnement qui qui est
sain en tout cas du moins on essaye
j'espère ça a marché
si je peux faire tant qu'à faire un tour
de dos tour de table de mot de la fin
enfin discret mais aussi tg de l'oeuvre
de prendre parce que man petit mettons à
dany turcotte qui freinent jo qui serait
mal reçue d'une certaine communauté
métier je sais très bien que de l'autre
côté un militant pour reporter la cause
que ce soit contre le fait m pour les
féministes lutte contre les racismes
dessus cette personne à occire se voit
énormément ce non plus de main et ne t'y
le problème c'est qu'un problème des
grandes et civisme grande écoute
la cyber intimidation qui vont dans tous
les sens c'est juste que je pense que
les personnes en situations marginales
ou ou des minorités sont un peu tanné de
se faire casser du sucre sur le dos avec
des dés des jeux président des énoncés
ou des states and qui les placent toutes
dans le même panier qui uniformise ces
gens là qui nous font oublier que chacun
de ces personnes ont une identité propre
ni un combat de tous les instants de la
fin ph ben moi j'avais ensuite ce
qu'elle exige pense que c'est aussi la
personne qui est monolithique et
personnes qui ont une pensée unique même
l'homme blanc privilégié six au point de
pensée unique puis je pense mais plus je
fais pas l'apologie de l'homme blanc six
le sont sur le point mais c'est que tout
le monde aime pensée unique en parlons
nous plus je pense ouais c'est ça être
doué pièce quasi